Two and five Canadians will hear the words, you have cancer. That's why every step and dollar raised matters. On September 19th, join thousands in Toronto for the Princess Margaret Cancer Foundation Walk. Challenge yourself, friends, and family to walk 21 kilometers in support of life-saving research. Together, we can carry the fire and help create a world free from the fear of cancer. Register today at pmcfwalk.ca. I saw my friend on the other side of the street. I was heading to school with the kids.
每五个加拿大人中就有两个会听到“你得了癌症”这句话。这就是为什么每一步努力和每一分捐款都至关重要。9月19日，加入多伦多成千上万人的行列，参加玛格丽特公主癌症基金会（Princess Margaret Cancer Foundation）的步行活动。挑战你自己、朋友和家人，步行21公里，支持挽救生命的癌症研究。让我们携手传递希望之火，共同创造一个不再有癌症恐惧的世界。立即在 pmcfwalk.ca 注册。我看到我的朋友在街对面。我正带着孩子们去学校。
I let go of mom's hand to wave. I had already forgotten their lunches. I ran over to hug her. She came out of nowhere. And then... It stopped. Sometimes the moments that never happen matter most. Volvo's automatic emergency braking helps ensure a safe ending for everyone.
我松开妈妈的手去挥手告别。我早就忘了他们的午餐。我跑过去拥抱她。她不知从哪儿冒出来的。然后……一切都停止了。有时，那些从未发生过的瞬间才最重要。沃尔沃的自动紧急制动系统有助于确保每个人都能平安回家。
Learn more at VolvoCars.a.com. Hello. Now, before we go to today's episode, I have some insanely exciting news for you. On Friday the 4th of September, Dominic and I will be forming live at the South Bank Centre in London. And better yet, we will be doing something completely new, something that no one has ever heard before on the rest is history. The ultimate Victorian adventure. So to give you just a little taste, we will be in Africa in 1860. The Emperor of Abyssinia, Theodore II, has kidnapped 59 Europeans and he is holding them hostage after descending into this demented rage because one of his fellow monarchs, Queen Victoria, has declined to answer his letters. I'm not making this up. And the British, after months and months of fruitless waiting, have lost patience and they have sent a military expedition and a general. General Napier, halfway around the world to save them. An expedition that includes thousands of mules, loads of elephants, and they've even had to build their own railway across the highlands of Abyssinia or Ethiopia to try to get to his mountain citadel. It is a bonkers story.
了解更多信息请访问 VolvoCars.a.com。大家好。在进入今天的话题之前，我有一个超级令人兴奋的消息要告诉大家。9月4日星期五，多米尼克和我将在伦敦南岸中心进行现场表演。更棒的是，我们将带来全新的内容，这是在《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）节目中从未听过的内容。一场终极的维多利亚时代冒险。为了让大家先睹为快，我们将回到1860年的非洲。阿比西尼亚皇帝西奥多二世绑架了59名欧洲人，并将他们扣为人质。他之所以陷入这种疯狂的愤怒，是因为他的同行君主维多利亚女王拒绝回复他的信件。我没编故事。英国人在经历了数月毫无结果的等待后失去了耐心，派遣了一支军事远征队和一位将军——纳皮尔将军，远渡重洋去营救他们。这支远征队包括数千头骡子、成群的大象，他们甚至不得不穿过阿比西尼亚（即埃塞俄比亚）的高地修建自己的铁路，试图到达他的山顶堡垒。这是一个疯狂的故事。
Yeah, it's absolutely extraordinary, full-blown British imperial epic, full of ludicrous behaviour, mad characters, colossal moustaches, everything that we love on The Rest is History. It is, though I say so myself, a guaranteed classic in the making. So you're probably thinking how can I get a ticket for this extraordinary Victorian adventure? Here is the answer. If you want to get a ticket for this event on Friday, the 4th of September, all you have to do is to go to The Rest Is History.com. It is as simple as that.
是的，这绝对是非同寻常的，是一部彻头彻尾的英国帝国史诗，充满了荒谬的行为、疯狂的人物、巨大的胡子，以及我们在《历史的其余部分》中所喜爱的一切。虽然是我自己说的，但这绝对是一部注定会成为经典的佳作。所以你可能在想，我该如何为这场非凡的维多利亚时代冒险买票呢？答案就在这里。如果你想购买9月4日星期五这场活动的门票，你只需要访问 TheRestIsHistory.com。就是这么简单。
You maybe have to part with some money. but it will be money very, very, very, very well spent. See you there. Mr Speaker, I am deeply patriotic. I never want to believe anything bad about our country. I never want to call into question the behaviour of our soldiers and our army, who I believe to be the finest in the world. and I have seen for myself the very difficult and dangerous circumstances in which we ask our soldiers to serve.
你可能需要花点钱，但这笔钱绝对绝对绝对花得非常值。到时见。议长先生，我深爱我的国家。我从不想相信关于我们国家的任何坏事。我从不想质疑我们士兵和军队的行为，我相信他们是世界上最优秀的。我亲眼目睹了我们要求士兵们服役的那些非常困难和危险的环境。
But the conclusions of this report are absolutely clear. There is no doubt, there is nothing equivocal, there are no ambiguities. What happened on Bloody Sunday was both unjustified and unjustifiable. It was wrong. What happened should never, ever have happened. The families of those who died should not have had to live with the pain and the hurt of that day and with a lifetime of loss. Some members of our armed forces acted wrongly.
但这份报告的结论非常明确。毫无疑问，没有任何含糊其辞，没有任何歧义。发生在“血腥星期日”的事情既是不公正的，也是不可辩解的。那是错误的。所发生的一切绝不应该发生。那些死者的家属本不应该承受那一天的痛苦和伤害，以及终身的失去。我们武装部队的一些成员行为不当。
The government is ultimately responsible for the conduct of the armed forces, and for that, on behalf of the government, indeed, on behalf of our country, I am deeply sorry. So that was former Prime Minister David Cameron speaking to the House of Commons on the 15th of June 2010. And it was his response to the report of the Saville inquiry, which had been set up 12 years earlier by Tony Blair, to investigate the single most controversial moment of the entire troubles. And that moment was the shooting and killing of 13 unarmed Catholic civilians by British paratroopers during a protest march in Derry on the 30th of January, 1972, a day that has gone down in infamy as Bloody Sunday.
政府最终要对武装部队的行为负责，因此，我谨代表政府，确实，谨代表我们的国家，深表歉意。以上是前首相戴维·卡梅伦于2010年6月15日在下议院发表的讲话。这是他对萨维尔调查报告的回应，该调查是托尼·布莱尔在12年前设立的，旨在调查整个“动荡时期”中最具争议的时刻。那一刻就是1972年1月30日，英国伞兵在德里的一次抗议游行中开枪打死了13名手无寸铁的天主教平民，这一天作为“血腥星期日”而臭名昭著。
And the Saville inquiry was actually the second official British investigation. The first under Lord Chief Justice Whidgery, a splendid name, was conducted just weeks after the event, and that one largely exonerated the paratroopers. But most people didn't agree with that conclusion. Certainly the families of the victims never accepted it. And of course, you too never accepted it. And their song helped to make Bloody Sunday a cause-celebra wherever popular music is listened to by earnest teenagers in bedrooms. So Tony Blair set up the Savile Inquiry as part of the peace process in 1998. And it was incredibly expensive.
萨维尔调查实际上是英国第二次官方调查。第一次调查是在首席大法官威德格里（Whidgery，一个响亮的名字）的主持下，在事件发生几周后进行的，那次调查在很大程度上为伞兵开脱了罪责。但大多数人并不认同这一结论。当然，受害者家属从未接受过它。当然，U2乐队也从未接受过。他们的歌曲帮助“血腥星期日”成为了全世界卧室里认真听流行音乐的青少年们所关注的焦点。所以托尼·布莱尔在1998年作为和平进程的一部分设立了萨维尔调查。而且它极其昂贵。
It cost almost 200 million pounds. And the Saville inquiry, unlike the Widdery report, it blamed the paratroopers for losing control and for lying about it afterwards, hence Cameron's statement afterwards. So it's obviously a notorious date in modern British and indeed Irish history. And today we'll explore the context for Bloody Sunday. We'll talk about what happened. day in January in 1972, why it mattered and how Northern Ireland spiraled into hell, basically,
它花费了近2亿英镑。与威德格里报告不同，萨维尔调查指责伞兵失去了控制，并在事后撒谎，这就是卡梅伦后来发表声明的原因。所以这显然是现代英国乃至爱尔兰历史上一个臭名昭著的日子。今天我们将探讨“血腥星期日”的背景。我们将讨论1972年1月那一天发生了什么，为什么它很重要，以及北爱尔兰是如何陷入地狱的，基本上，
in the worst year of the troubles. But first, by way of recap, let's pick up in the autumn of 1971. So in the last episode, we talked about the disaster of internment, which was that August, the new stories about the torture of the people who were interned, and then the sectarian bomb attacks that autumn. So the four steps, the Red Lion pubs, the Mubbs, the Mids, the Mids, the McGurks Bar attack and then the Balmoral Furniture showroom. Now amid all this, in October of that year, 71, relatively new Stormont Prime Minister Brian Faulkner flies to London. And he has come to brief Ted Heath on the desperate security situation.
在“动荡时期”最糟糕的一年里。但首先，回顾一下，让我们回到1971年的秋天。在上一集中，我们谈到了8月份那场灾难性的拘留行动，关于被拘留者遭受酷刑的新闻，以及那年秋天的宗派炸弹袭击。比如四步（Four Steps）、红狮酒吧（Red Lion pubs）、Mubbs、Mids、麦格克酒吧（McGurks Bar）袭击，然后是巴尔莫勒尔家具展厅（Balmoral Furniture showroom）。在这一切之中，那年10月，相对较新的斯托蒙特（Stormont）首相布莱恩·福克纳飞往伦敦。他来向泰德·希思（Ted Heath）通报绝望的安全局势。
And Faulkner says to him, look, this is dreadful. If these bombings continue, a breakdown in government might occur in a matter of weeks. And Heath says to him, I mean, this is very bad news. I agree. It's awful. and this cannot go on, the British people, the British public, is losing patience. Now, if you think about their options at this point, if we step back and think about their options, what can the British government plausibly do?
福克纳对他说，看，这太可怕了。如果这些爆炸继续下去，政府可能会在几周内崩溃。希思对他说，我的意思是，这是非常糟糕的消息。我同意。这太糟糕了，这种情况不能再继续下去了，英国人民，英国公众，正在失去耐心。现在，如果你考虑他们此时的选择，如果我们退后一步思考他们的选择，英国政府能做些什么呢？
So one option, which would be the sort of the John Lennon option, and of course the option that the provisional IRA would like, the troops out movement, lots of people on the left who think this is Britain's Vietnam, but also lots of ordinary people in Britain who don't, you know, then they didn't give a damn about Northern Ireland. They don't understand why the British Army is there and why people are dying. This option would be to get out. To just say, fine, forget it.
所以一个选择，也就是所谓的约翰·列侬式的选择，当然也是临时爱尔兰共和军（IRA）所希望的选择，即“撤军运动”。许多左翼人士认为这是英国的越南，但也有许多普通的英国人，你知道，他们根本不在乎北爱尔兰。他们不明白为什么英国军队在那里，为什么人们在死去。这个选择就是撤出。就说，好吧，算了吧。
We're going home. We're going to leave you to your own devices. So the Home Secretary, Reginald Mordling, we talked about him last time. Very clever, very corrupt, lazy, off his face on gin all the time. He's slightly of this mind. So there's a story about a group of community relations experts coming to meet him at his office. And they found him slumped in an armchair. And he was completely sort of exhausted and demoralised.
我们要回家了。我们要让你们自生自灭。所以内政大臣雷金纳德·莫德林（Reginald Maudling），我们上次谈到过他。非常聪明，非常腐败，懒惰，整天喝杜松子酒喝得神志不清。他有点这种想法。所以有一个故事说，一群社区关系专家去他的办公室见他。他们发现他瘫在扶手椅上。他完全精疲力竭，士气低落。
And he said, so what do we do? Arm the Protestants and get out? And obviously, you know, this is an option. It's the degole option, isn't it, with Algeria? Right, exactly. Now, why don't people do that? Well, a difference between Algeria and Northern Ireland. I can remember I actually had it, when I was at university, a tutor of mine,
他说，那我们该怎么办？武装新教徒然后撤出？显然，你知道，这是一个选择。这就是戴高乐在阿尔及利亚的选择，对吧？没错，正是如此。那么，为什么人们不这样做呢？嗯，阿尔及利亚和北爱尔兰之间有区别。我记得我实际上在大学时，我的一位导师，
encouraged me to see similarities between the situation in Algeria and that's a northern island. But on obvious differences, in Algeria, the people who want to stay part of France the pi noir as they're called they are very much a minority but in Northern Ireland a majority of people there if you regard it as a separate entity
鼓励我看看阿尔及利亚的情况和北爱尔兰的情况之间的相似之处。但有明显的区别，在阿尔及利亚，那些想留在法国的人，也就是所谓的“黑脚”（Pieds-Noirs），他们确实是少数，但在北爱尔兰，如果你把它看作一个独立的实体，那里的大多数人，
a majority of people in that entity want to remain part of the United Kingdom also they've been there since the 17th century haven't they? They've been there a long time there are a million of them it's a very unusual thing for a country to basically dismember itself
那个实体中的大多数人希望留在联合王国。而且他们从17世纪就在那里了，不是吗？他们已经在那里很久了，有一百万人。一个国家基本上把自己肢解，
to throw away part of its own territory where the majority of the population want to remain part of that country and perhaps more importantly almost everybody looking at the situation agrees that if the British army did withdraw and if Britain did go home as it were
抛弃自己的一部分领土，而那里的多数人口希望留在那个国家，这在世界上是非常罕见的。也许更重要的是，几乎所有观察局势的人都同意，如果英军真的撤出，如果英国真的回家了，
the result would be an absolute sectarian free-for-all there would be massive bloodshed probably effectively we've talked about a low-level civil war there would be a proper civil war and the Republic of Ireland would have to get involved And there'd also be massive blowback in Britain, right? I mean, at the very least, there'd be hundreds of thousands of Protestant refugees, presumably crossing to mainland Britain. Yeah, completely the wood.
结果将是一场彻底的宗派大混战。会有大规模的流血事件，可能实际上我们谈论的是一场低强度的内战，那将是一场真正的内战，爱尔兰共和国将不得不卷入其中。而且在英国也会有巨大的反弹，对吧？我的意思是，至少会有成千上万的新教难民，大概会涌向英国本土。是的，完全会。
Completely the wood. And of course, this is why, the fact that it would be so chaotic, this is why, in the course of the 1970s, in private, the Irish government, are desperate for this not to happen. So in 1975, I mean, we'll maybe talk about this when we come to it in the future series. In 1975, the Irish government's actually getting in touch with Henry Kissinger, the US Secretary of State, and they say, we want you to put pressure on the British, Do not withdraw. It's the last thing what we in Dublin want. We don't want a United Ireland right away. Please stay and hold the line. And there's an element in the Irish government thinking that still secretly has a little bit of that. I think so. I think undoubtedly, undoubtedly that it would be you'd be importing a large number of people who basically hate your
完全会。当然，这就是为什么，因为它会如此混乱，这就是为什么在1970年代，私下里，爱尔兰政府非常渴望这种情况不要发生。所以在1975年，我的意思是，我们以后在未来的系列节目中可能会谈到这一点。1975年，爱尔兰政府实际上与美国国务卿亨利·基辛格取得了联系，他们说，我们希望你向英国施压，不要撤军。这是我们在都柏林最不希望发生的事。我们不想马上实现爱尔兰统一。请留下来，守住防线。爱尔兰政府中有一种想法，私下里仍然有一点这种想法。我想是的。我想毫无疑问，毫无疑问，你会引入大量基本上憎恨你，
state. And do you really want to do that? So people keep coming back to this idea. This sort of what they see is another kind of semi-nuclear option. Scrap self-government in Northern Ireland and put it under direct rule from London. Heath hesitates to do that still at this point. Why? Because the Ministry of Defence have told him that if you do that, you can't be certain that local public officials
国家的人。你真的想那样做吗？所以人们不断回到这个想法。这被他们视为另一种准核选项。废除北爱尔兰的自治，实行伦敦的直接统治。希思此时仍然对此犹豫不决。为什么？因为国防部告诉他，如果你这样做，你不能确定当地的公职人员，
will follow your orders. There might be a complete breakdown of public services. The whole country might fall apart. British military intelligence says the risk of doing this is if the Protestants turn against us, we will be fighting. and I quote, fighting both sides in the middle of a civil war. At this point, the British public would say, well, this is mad, we should all come,
会听从你的命令。公共服务可能会彻底崩溃。整个国家可能会分崩离析。英国军事情报部门说，这样做的风险是，如果新教徒反抗我们，我们将不得不战斗，我引用一下，“在内战中同时与双方作战”。此时，英国公众会说，好吧，这太疯狂了，我们应该全部，
our troops should come home, and then you would get the massive bloodbath anyway. And so after all this, Heath and his ministers decide, what are we going to do? We'll just keep doing what we've been doing. We'll muddle on. We'll muddle through. And crucially, we must keep Brian Faulkner in power, because if he falls, we have no other option. So where does this leave the British army on the ground? We haven't really talked much about them in this series.
我们的军队应该回家，然后你无论如何都会得到大规模的血洗。所以经过这一切，希思和他的部长们决定，我们该怎么办？我们只会继续做我们一直在做的事情。我们将得过且过。我们将混过去。至关重要的是，我们必须让布莱恩·福克纳继续掌权，因为如果他倒台，我们就没有其他选择了。那么这让地面的英军处于什么境地呢？在这个系列中我们还没有真正谈论过他们。
initially there are about 7,000 of them. This has now doubled to 15,000. And obviously they're not there, any illusion of them being there as sort of jolly peacemakers having fish and chips and cups of tears long since disappeared. They're in this quagmire, hence the Vietnam comparisons. It's this sort of, I think the weird thing about it for them is it's like a parallel universe, kind of apocalyptic Britain.
最初大约有7000人。现在已经增加到15000人。显然他们不在那里，任何关于他们是快乐的维和人员，吃着炸鱼薯条喝着茶的幻想早已消失了。他们陷入了这个泥潭，这就是越南比较的由来。我认为对他们来说奇怪的是，这就像一个平行宇宙，某种末日般的英国。
So there's in Peter Taylor's book, Brits about the experience of the army. He talks about this young officer who flew into Belfast for the first time in August 1971. And this officer looked down and he said you could see roads that had been blocked and barricaded. You could see fires from bonfires, burning cars and burning houses. And he said, the mad thing is that all this was happening in a city of the United Kingdom with red telephone boxes and red letter boxes.
彼得·泰勒（Peter Taylor）的书《英国人》（Brits）中关于军队的经历。他谈到了一位年轻军官，他在1971年8月第一次飞往贝尔法斯特。这位军官向下看，他说你可以看到被封锁和设置路障的道路。你可以看到篝火、燃烧的汽车和燃烧的房子。他说，疯狂的是，这一切都发生在一个拥有红色电话亭和红色信箱的联合王国城市里。
I mean, that's the thing that kind of messes with the soldier's heads in a way. And of course, it's very dangerous. So every month soldiers are dying 42 of them died in 1971 killed by the IRA 64 of them died in 1972 I mentioned in the last episode Kevin Myers the RTE journalist
我的意思是，这就是那种在某种程度上扰乱士兵头脑的事情。当然，这非常危险。所以每个月都有士兵死亡，1971年有42人死于爱尔兰共和军之手，1972年有64人死亡。我在上一集中提到了爱尔兰广播电视（RTE）记者凯文·迈尔斯（Kevin Myers），
his memoir watching the door there's a moment in that a very sort of evocative passage he remembers in the summer of 1972 being on this burned out kind of Belfast estate and watching a teenage IRA gunman open fire on a British patrol
他的回忆录《守门》（Watching the Door），其中有一个时刻，一段非常令人回味的段落，他记得在1972年的夏天，身处贝尔法斯特一个被烧毁的住宅区，看着一名十几岁的爱尔兰共和军枪手向一支英国巡逻队开火，
and one of the British soldiers being left bleeding to death in the middle of the street and children laughing and jeering him as he lay there dying. And Myers, I mentioned him last time, Irish Catholic parentage born in Leicester, ended up working for Irish TV. In his memoir he actually says the one thing that's underrated is what he calls the forbearance and good cheer of the British troops. He says they're under the worst provocation
其中一名英国士兵倒在街中央流血致死，孩子们在他垂死时对他嘲笑和讥讽。迈尔斯，我上次提到过他，爱尔兰天主教血统，出生在莱斯特，最终为爱尔兰电视台工作。在他的回忆录中，他实际上说被低估的一件事是他所说的英国军队的“克制和好心情”。他说他们是在最恶劣的挑衅下，
and it's amazing that they behaved as well as they did. Of course, that's not an argument you often hear. and may seem in Congress, given the subject of today's episode. Now, even the soldiers themselves, of course, admit that they're not perfect. So most of these men, especially we're talking about the rank and file, the squatties. They are relatively poorly educated, young men. Lots of them in their late teens, early 20s. When you look at the ages and the casualty list, it's stunning how young they are, actually.
表现得如此之好，真是令人惊叹。当然，这不是你经常听到的论点。考虑到今天这一集的主题，这似乎有些不协调。现在，即使是士兵们自己，当然也承认他们并不完美。所以这些人中的大多数，特别是我们谈论的普通士兵，即“squatties”。他们是受教育程度相对较低的年轻人。他们中的许多人十几岁或二十出头。当你查看年龄和伤亡名单时，他们如此年轻，这真的很令人震惊。
They're often from working-class estates in the cities of Northern England. These are people to whom turning the other cheek does not necessarily come naturally and many of them actually come to hate the people of Northern Ireland the bloke called Jim who Peter Taylor quotes You see these blokes dying in gutters In a war which is not classed as a war It makes you bloody bitter and it fills you with hate
他们通常来自英格兰北部城市的工人阶级社区。这些人并不自然地习惯于“转过另一边脸”，他们中的许多人实际上开始憎恨北爱尔兰人民。彼得·泰勒引用的那个叫吉姆的人，你看到这些家伙死在阴沟里，在一场不被归类为战争的战争中，这让你感到非常痛苦，充满了仇恨。
I hated the people in those areas With an intensity that used to make me feel almost physically sick And Jim in his interview he talks about you know, we would go in, we would kick in their doors, who would smash their windows, when we got a chance we would smash in their TV screens. And I think you can see in the context how that would seem, how young men probably would behave like that. Can I just ask about the officers? Because I don't know if you've seen the adaptation of Say Nothing. I've not.
我以一种让我感到几乎生理上恶心的强度憎恨那些地区的人。吉姆在采访中谈到，你知道，我们会进去，我们会踢开他们的门，我们会砸碎他们的窗户，有机会时我们会砸碎他们的电视屏幕。我认为你可以看出在那种背景下，年轻人可能会那样做。我可以问一下关于军官的事吗？因为我不知道你是否看过《不要说》（Say Nothing）的改编剧。我没看过。
I've read the book, but not seen the TV series. So about two sisters who joined the IRA. Yeah. And Rory Keneer plays a, a bro. British intelligence officer absolutely brilliantly, I have to say. And he has kind of counterinsurgency experience from various British colonial engagements. Yeah. And he is played with a very icy heart. I think it's fair to say. And is that how the British officer class see what's going on? Do they similarly, you're saying, you know, I hate these people, this guy that gets quoted. Do you think the British officer
我读过书，但没看过电视剧。关于两个加入爱尔兰共和军的姐妹。是的。罗里·金尼尔（Rory Kinnear）饰演一名英国情报官员，我必须说演得非常出色。他有来自各种英国殖民地参与的平叛经验。是的。他被塑造成一颗非常冰冷的心。我认为这样说是公平的。英国军官阶层是这样看待正在发生的事情的吗？他们是否也像你说的，那个被引用的人说“我憎恨这些人”，你认为英国军官，
class feel the same? It's hard to generalise. Not all of them hate the local people, of course, but I think a lot of the British officer class, I mean, if you're in that position, the chances are that you might have served in the colonial engagement earlier in the 60s in Aden or whatever. So I think it's probably fair. There's quite a few of the British officer class view it through a colonial prism, as it were, to use the kind of jargon. I think they don't, they come to see, they come to have contempt or a dislike, a contempt for, dislike of the locals on all sides. So you don't find, you know, it's not like they're falling over themselves to pour syrup over the, the, the, the, the uniest population. I think they, they come to feel like, you know, it's us against the world.
阶层也有同样的感觉吗？很难一概而论。当然，并非所有人都憎恨当地人，但我认为许多英国军官阶层，我的意思是，如果你处于那个位置，你很可能在60年代早期的亚丁或其他地方的殖民地参与中服役过。所以我认为这可能是公平的。相当多的英国军官阶层以某种殖民棱镜来看待它，用那种术语来说。我认为他们不会，他们开始对各方的当地人产生蔑视或厌恶。所以你不会发现，你知道，他们并不是争先恐后地向联合派人口倾注糖浆。我认为他们开始觉得，你知道，这是我们对抗世界。
They're in an alien environment. Everybody's against them. They don't understand it. They're sick of it. Their mates are dying. And that's true whether you're the old Etonian officer or whether you're the kid who left school at 16 and went straight into the army, I think. Right. because the officer class will be complicit in what happens on Bloody Sunday,
他们处于一个陌生的环境中。每个人都反对他们。他们不理解它。他们厌倦了它。他们的伙伴正在死去。无论你是老伊顿公学的军官，还是16岁离开学校直接参军的孩子，我想这都是事实。没错。因为军官阶层将对“血腥星期日”发生的事情负有同谋责任，
just as much as the squatties who do the firing. Well, when we come to Bloody Sunday, I mean, the single most best-known British soldier involved in Bloody Sunday is very much an officer-class kind of person, as we shall see. So the Catholic population at this point, the relationship between them and the army is just incredibly toxic. The Catholic population view the army's bullying occupiers, the army view them as their enemies,
就像那些开枪的普通士兵一样。嗯，当我们谈到“血腥星期日”时，我的意思是，参与“血腥星期日”的最著名的英国士兵确实是一个军官阶层的人，正如我们将要看到的。所以此时的天主教人口，他们与军队之间的关系简直是极其有毒的。天主教人口将军队视为欺凌的占领者，军队将他们视为敌人，
And nowhere is this more pronounced than the city where the British Army had first arrived, which is London Derry or Derry. And a reminder for people, you know, the name is the, gives you a clue to its sort of fractured identity. It's about 60-40 Catholic Protestant. It's economically really struggling. The mood in Derry is very fractious and very bitter and has been since the late 60s. In fact, the scars of the fighting in 1969 at this point have still not healed. There are still burned out shops, burned out businesses.
这一点在英军首次抵达的城市，即伦敦德里（Londonderry）或德里（Derry），表现得最为明显。提醒一下大家，你知道，这个名字给了你关于它那种破碎身份的线索。它大约是60%天主教徒，40%新教徒。它在经济上真的很挣扎。德里的气氛非常易怒且苦涩，自60年代末以来一直如此。事实上，1969年战斗的伤疤此时仍未愈合。仍然有被烧毁的商店，被烧毁的企业。
There are huge barricades that block off Catholic estates, so particularly in an area that is called Free Derry. You know, basically there's a big mural. It says, you are now entering free dairy. There are barricades there. The entrances to the estate, the bogside are guarded by vigilantes in masks and balaclavas who are often openly carrying guns. And the British Army do not try and pull these barriers. down. No, they do not. And from this area, from free dairy, gangs of unemployed teenagers who call themselves the dairy young hooligans. That's what it says on the tin, I guess.
有巨大的路障封锁了天主教社区，特别是在一个被称为“自由德里”（Free Derry）的地区。你知道，基本上有一幅巨大的壁画。上面写着：你现在进入了自由德里。那里有路障。博格赛德（Bogside）社区的入口由戴着面具和巴拉克拉瓦头套的治安维持人员守卫，他们通常公开携带枪支。英国军队并没有试图拆除这些障碍。不，他们没有。从这个地区，从自由德里，一群失业的青少年，他们自称为“德里年轻流氓”（Derry Young Hooligans）。我想这就是它的本质。
That's what it says on the tin, exactly. They go out on kind of raids into the city center, and they will loot shops, and they will try to burn Protestant-owned businesses and things like this. So by the second half of 1971, there was a sense that, you know, legitimate authority in dairy has pretty much broken down. The Protestant business owners, are outraged of this. They estimate their losses from arson at about four million pounds. A lot of money then. They are furious that the RUC, the police and the British Army are not protecting them. And every day there are these sort of scuffles and confrontations at the edge of the bogside, where teenagers will throw stones at British Army patrols, but the patrols won't go in.
这就是它的本质，没错。他们会进行某种进入市中心的突袭，他们会抢劫商店，他们会试图烧毁新教徒拥有的企业等等。所以到了1971年下半年，人们感觉到，你知道，德里的合法权威已经基本崩溃了。新教徒企业主对此感到愤怒。他们估计因纵火造成的损失约为400万英镑。那时的钱很多。他们对皇家阿尔斯特警队（RUC）和英国军队没有保护他们感到愤怒。每天在博格赛德的边缘都会发生这种争吵和对抗，青少年会向英国军队巡逻队投掷石块，但巡逻队不会进去。
And there are some people in the army who find this incredibly frustrating and humiliating. One of these people is a man called Lieutenant Colonel Derek Wilford, who commands the first battalion of the parachute regiment. And Wilford says of these patrols in Derry, they just stood there in the road like Aunt Salas and they never went forward. It was horrifying. In other words, he's embarrassed to be a British officer
军队里有些人觉得这非常令人沮丧和羞辱。其中一个人叫德里克·威尔福德（Derek Wilford）中校，他指挥伞兵团第一营。威尔福德在谈到德里的这些巡逻时说，他们只是像“安特·萨利”（Aunt Sallies，一种投掷游戏中的靶子）一样站在路上，从不前进。这太可怕了。换句话说，他为自己是一名英国军官感到尴尬，
when this is happening. And the paras are the most... The hardest of the heart, as they see themselves. And Wilford's view is shared by the new British commander in Northern Ireland, Major General Robert Ford, who arrives in the late summer of 1971. Ford looks at the maps and he sees black lines on the army maps, that mark free dairy
当这种情况发生时。而伞兵是最……他们自认为是硬汉中的硬汉。威尔福德的观点得到了北爱尔兰新任英国指挥官罗伯特·福特（Robert Ford）少将的认同，他于1971年夏末抵达。福特看着地图，他看到军队地图上有黑线，标记着自由德里，
and he says this is an embarrassment we shouldn't have such lines on our maps the local officers have been too soft and actually by being too soft they invite provocation and they put our men's lives at risk and men are dying so pretty much one a month
他说这是一种尴尬，我们的地图上不应该有这样的线。当地军官太软弱了，实际上通过太软弱，他们招致了挑衅，并将我们士兵的生命置于危险之中，而且人们正在死去，所以几乎每个月，
is being shot by snipers and killed and probably twice that number being wounded and Ford thinks this is getting worse because basically the people in the bogside are becoming emboldened So on the 14th of December, Ford writes to his officers and he says, the situation in Derry is deteriorating. It's insane that we have abandoned part of the second city of Northern Ireland to 40 IRA gunmen and 500 hooligans. And we've done nothing at all about it.
都有人被狙击手射杀，大约有两倍的人受伤，福特认为情况正在恶化，因为基本上博格赛德的人变得胆大妄为了。所以12月14日，福特写信给他的军官，他说，德里的局势正在恶化。我们把北爱尔兰第二大城市的一部分遗弃给40名爱尔兰共和军枪手和500名流氓，这太疯狂了。我们对此什么也没做。
He says the correct military solution, these are his words, would be to cross the line into the no-go area, go in hard and root out the IRA. But, he says, the drug. Drawbacks are so serious that I want to hold off doing that for the time being. Why? Because, and I quote, the risk of casualties is high, and apart from gunmen or bombers, so-called unarmed rioters, possibly teenagers, are certain to be shot in the initial phases. Much will be made of the invasion of dairy and the slaughter of the innocent. So these are very prescient words from Major General Ford. Anyway, over Christmas, there's no improvement. So on the 7th of January, Ford writes another report,
他说正确的军事解决方案，这是他的原话，是越过界线进入禁区，强硬进入并铲除爱尔兰共和军。但是，他说，缺点太严重了，我想暂时搁置这样做。为什么？因为，我引用一下，“伤亡风险很高，除了枪手或炸弹袭击者外，所谓的非武装暴徒，可能是青少年，在初期阶段肯定会被射杀。德里的入侵和无辜者的屠杀将被大肆渲染。”所以这些是福特少将非常有先见之明的话。无论如何，圣诞节期间，情况没有改善。所以1月7日，福特写了另一份报告，
and this becomes incredibly controversial later on. He says things are getting even worse. Our armoured cars, when they pass, they're surrounded by these teenagers and attacked, and the soldiers get out. And when the soldiers get out, snipers on the high-rise Rossville flats shoot at them and sometimes wound or kill them. This is absolutely unacceptable. we have to get tough
这在后来变得极其有争议。他说情况变得更糟了。我们的装甲车经过时，被这些青少年包围并攻击，士兵们下车了。当士兵们下车时，高层罗斯维尔公寓（Rossville flats）的狙击手向他们射击，有时会打伤或打死他们。这绝对是不可接受的。我们必须强硬起来，
and he goes on to say the only way that we can restore law and order in dairy is to and I quote shoot selected ringleaders amongst the dairy young hooligans after clear warnings have been issued you know we have to shoot some of these teenagers
他接着说，我们恢复德里法律和秩序的唯一方法是，我引用一下，“射杀德里年轻流氓中的选定头目，在发出明确警告后”，你知道，我们必须射杀其中一些青少年，
but he says he goes on to say we do not want to have unnecessary casualties we don't want to bring a firestorm of criticism down upon us so we will use a particular kind of ammunition so 0.22 inch ammunition, it's much less likely to kill people and it's much less likely to cause accidental casualties by killing people in the vicinity.
但他接着说，我们不想造成不必要的伤亡，我们不想招致批评的风暴。所以我们将使用一种特殊的弹药，即0.22英寸弹药，它杀人的可能性要小得多，而且不太可能通过杀死附近的人造成意外伤亡。
In other words, I think what Ford is basically saying is, I want us to shoot people but not necessarily to kill them. Yeah, salutary violence. Exactly. So that was on the 7th of January, 1972. Now, 11 days later, Brian Fultner, the Prime Minister, announces a ban on all parades in Derry. However, the civil rights group, NICRA, which we talked about a couple of episodes ago.
换句话说，我认为福特基本上是在说，我希望我们射杀人，但不一定非要杀死他们。是的，惩戒性的暴力。没错。所以那是1972年1月7日。现在，11天后，首相布莱恩·福克纳宣布在德里禁止所有游行。然而，民权组织NICRA，我们几集前谈到过，
Sounds very sinister, doesn't it? Sounds like a kind of pro-smoking lobby. Yeah, I guess so. Anyway, this group, they have planned a civil rights march to protest against internment, which of course was introduced in August. And this march is scheduled for Sunday the 30th of January. And this is the day that will go down as bloody Sunday. So they've
听起来很阴险，不是吗？听起来像某种支持吸烟的游说团体。是的，我想是吧。无论如何，这个组织，他们计划了一场民权游行，以抗议拘留，当然这是8月份引入的。这场游行定于1月30日星期日。这就是将被称为“血腥星期日”的日子。所以他们，
They want to do this march Which is technically illegal And we come now to the day Probably no day In recent British history Perhaps all British history Has been chronicled so exhaustively D-Day perhaps
他们想进行这场游行，这在技术上是非法的。我们现在来到这一天，可能没有哪一天，在近代英国历史上，也许是整个英国历史上，被如此详尽地记录过。也许是诺曼底登陆日（D-Day），
Possibly But when I tell you this The Saffel report Which covers this day comes to 10 volumes 5,036 pages And about 2.5 million words So you haven't listened to we have ways on D-Day
可能。但当我告诉你，萨维尔报告涵盖了这一天，共有10卷，5036页，约250万字。所以你没听过关于诺曼底登陆日的节目，
because I think there's a lot more. They've spent more, your brother and Al Murray. Surely Arnhem. Arnhem, yes. It's always Arnhem with them, isn't it? Anyway, are you and I are going to spend two and a half million words and 5,000 pages on Bloody Sunday?
因为我认为还有更多。他们花得更多，你的兄弟和阿尔·默里（Al Murray）。肯定是阿纳姆（Arnhem）。阿纳姆，是的。对他们来说总是阿纳姆，不是吗？无论如何，你和我打算在“血腥星期日”上花费250万字和5000页吗？
Big spoiler alert for the listeners, we are not. We're going to give a very simplified version. If you want to read the Saville report, it is online and we'll see you in 10 years. So here is what happens. The army and the police authorities in the city agree that if the march goes ahead, which it clearly is going to, the marches
给听众一个大剧透，我们不会。我们将提供一个非常简化的版本。如果你想阅读萨维尔报告，它在网上，我们10年后见。所以这就是发生的事情。该市的军队和警察当局同意，如果游行继续进行，这显然是肯定的，游行者，
are going to defy the government's instructions. They want to keep it out of the city centre because they want to avoid more attacks on the shops. So we'll close off the city centre, we'll keep the marches within the Catholic areas. If it turns violent, they say we're going to use the army to scoop up as many rioters as possible. But we'll be careful about this. You know, we'll proceed with caution. The army should only go in after specific orders and don't confuse rioters and marchers. You know, we don't want bad publicity. Heaven for fend. Not bad publicity. Basically, if you've got well-meaning people waving placards, leave them alone. If you've got people throwing bricks at you with masks on, they're the people
将无视政府的指示。他们想把它挡在市中心之外，因为他们想避免对商店的更多攻击。所以我们将关闭市中心，我们将把游行者限制在天主教区域内。如果它变得暴力，他们说我们将使用军队尽可能多地抓捕暴徒。但我们会小心这一点。你知道，我们将谨慎行事。军队应该只在接到具体命令后进入，不要混淆暴徒和游行者。你知道，我们不想要坏的宣传。天哪，禁止。不是坏的宣传。基本上，如果你有善意的人挥舞标语牌，别管他们。如果你有戴着面具向你扔砖头的人，他们就是，
you arrest. Now, who's going to do the scooping? General Ford thinks that the army and Derry have been too passive, of course. So as the arresting force, he sends to the hardest and most aggressive men that he has. And this is Lieutenant Colonel Wilford's first battalion of the Parra regiment. Now, they're the hardest men. Wilford himself is a really remarkable man actually to be commanding such men. Amazing story. So he came from, I think, Leicestershire.
你要逮捕的人。现在，谁来负责抓捕？福特将军认为德里的军队太被动了，当然。所以作为抓捕部队，他派出了他所拥有的最强硬、最具侵略性的人。这就是威尔福德中校的伞兵团第一营。现在，他们是最强硬的人。威尔福德本人实际上是一个非常了不起的人，竟然能指挥这样的人。惊人的故事。所以他来自，我想是莱斯特郡。
He was born to a single mother. He was brought up by his grandparents and an anonymous donor paid for him to go to Loughborough Grammar School. At Loughborough Grammar School, he turned out to be an absolutely brilliant classicist and actor. So he was given a place at Rada, the Royal Academy of Dramatic Arts, where all the sort of top lovers go.
他由单身母亲抚养长大。他由祖父母抚养，一位匿名捐赠者支付了他去拉夫堡文法学校（Loughborough Grammar School）的费用。在拉夫堡文法学校，他证明自己是一个绝对出色的古典学者和演员。所以他被皇家戏剧艺术学院（RADA）录取了，那是所有顶级演员去的地方。
He turned it down and ended up joining the army. His idea of relaxation is to read Virgil and Marcus Aurelius in the original, in Latin. It's a very first world war in the trenches. Very much, although less First World War, after he left the army, I was reading obituous of him today, and this blew my mind.
他拒绝了，最终加入了军队。他放松的方式是阅读拉丁文原版的维吉尔和马可·奥勒留。这非常像第一次世界大战在战壕里。非常像，虽然不太像第一次世界大战，在他离开军队后，我今天在读他的讣告，这让我大吃一惊。
After he left the army, with perhaps a slightly check of reputation, he grew a ponytail and became a Belgian antiques dealer. It's an unexpected development. It's a massively unexpected development. Anyway, in 1972, this bloke commands one of the most feared battalions in the British army. They are ultra-professional, ultra-aggressive. He always has his men kind of blacking up with their faces and wearing camouflage. He says, you know, we're fighters and killers.
在他离开军队后，名声可能稍微有点受损，他留了马尾辫，成为了一名比利时古董商。这是一个意想不到的发展。这是一个非常意想不到的发展。无论如何，在1972年，这个家伙指挥着英国军队中最令人恐惧的营之一。他们超级专业，超级激进。他总是让他的手下把脸涂黑，穿着迷彩服。他说，你知道，我们是战士和杀手。
We're not messing around here. What kind of camouflage are you wearing in Derry? You kind of dress up in, it looked like concrete or something. Dress as a tower block. A ballard. I don't know. I think you're just wearing it in case you suddenly sent to Malaya at a moment's notice. Well, anyway, he asked himself what would Marcus Aurelius do?
我们不是在这里胡闹。你在德里穿什么样的迷彩服？你打扮成混凝土之类的东西。打扮成塔楼。一个系船柱。我不知道。我想你只是穿着它，以防你突然被派往马来亚。好吧，无论如何，他问自己马可·奥勒留会怎么做？
Marcus Aurelius would be wearing green combat fatigues, no? No, he wouldn't. He'd be dressing up as bollards. Fooling the rioters. Pouting. So even before Bloody Sunday, the Paris, these paras had a reputation, shall we say. So a few days beforehand, the then young journalist Simon Hoggart called them in print, they are the troops most hated by Catholics and troubled areas.
马可·奥勒留会穿着绿色战斗服，不是吗？不，他不会。他会打扮成系船柱。愚弄暴徒。撅着嘴。所以即使在“血腥星期日”之前，伞兵，这些伞兵就有名声，我们可以这么说。所以几天前，当时的年轻记者西蒙·霍加特（Simon Hoggart）在印刷品中称他们为“天主教徒和动荡地区最憎恨的部队”。
And he said other British officers regard them as little better than thugs in uniform. And actually other officers thought it was a great mistake to send in the Paris. And in Peter Taylor's book Brits, he quotes officers who said, at the time it is mad to be using them to police a non-violent civil rights march. But of course, Ford wants to use the power as precisely because he thinks it will be violent. The atmosphere in Derry is very tense. Just three days before the march, the IRA had ambushed an RUC patrol car and they'd killed two policemen. And Ford's officers on the ground say to him,
他说其他英国军官认为他们不过是穿着制服的暴徒。实际上其他军官认为派伞兵进去是一个巨大的错误。在彼得·泰勒的书《英国人》中，他引用了当时军官的话说，用他们来维持非暴力民权游行的治安是疯狂的。但当然，福特想使用伞兵正是因为他认为这会变得暴力。德里的气氛非常紧张。就在游行前三天，爱尔兰共和军伏击了一辆皇家阿尔斯特警队巡逻车，打死了两名警察。福特在现场的军官对他说，
look, this march may start peacefully. but the dairy young hooligans backed up by the gunmen, this is a quote, the derry young hooligans backed up by the gunmen will undoubtedly take control at an early stage. And what they're particularly worried about, this may actually remind people a very unlikely parallel, which is the German invasion of Belgium in 1914. What they're really worried about is snipers, you know, people shooting from roofs and from sort of behind barricades and things.
看，这场游行可能开始时是和平的。但由枪手支持的“德里年轻流氓”，这是一个引用，“由枪手支持的德里年轻流氓无疑会在早期阶段控制局面。”他们特别担心的是，这实际上可能会让人们想起一个非常不可能的相似之处，即1914年德国入侵比利时。他们真正担心的是狙击手，你知道，从屋顶和路障后面射击的人等等。
The Paris operational orders explicitly wore, warn them. You should expect IRA terrorist activity. Almost certainly, snipers, petrol bombers and nail bombers will support the rioters. And snipers are their biggest fear. Snipers had killed 24 soldiers in the course of 1971. So when you, if you're a para and you wake up first thing in the morning, probably the threat of the sniper is the first thing you think of. But the parrars have the reputation they do because they are gung-ho, because they're not frightened. So one of them later remembers his commanding officer's words the night before. Let's teach them a lesson.
伞兵的作战命令明确警告他们。你应该预料到爱尔兰共和军的恐怖活动。几乎可以肯定，狙击手、汽油弹投掷者和钉子炸弹投掷者将支持暴徒。狙击手是他们最大的恐惧。狙击手在1971年杀死了24名士兵。所以当你，如果你是一名伞兵，你一大早醒来，狙击手的威胁可能是你首先想到的事情。但伞兵之所以有这样的名声，是因为他们好战，因为他们不害怕。所以其中一个人后来记得他指挥官前一天晚上的话。让我们给他们一个教训。
We want some kills tomorrow. Anyway, so we get to the day itself. When you dig into the Savile inquiry, you know, unless you've got like 10 years to spend reading this stuff, it's daunting the amount of detail, minute by minute detail. But actually, the big picture of it is pretty straightforward. Lunchtime the marches assemble. And they set off just before 3 o'clock in the afternoon. There were about 12,000 of them.
我们明天想要一些战果。无论如何，我们来到了这一天。当你深入研究萨维尔调查时，你知道，除非你有10年的时间来阅读这些东西，否则细节的量是令人望而生畏的，逐分钟的细节。但实际上，大局是非常直接的。午餐时间游行者集合。他们在下午3点前出发。大约有12000人。
And the atmosphere, contrary to expectation at first, is pretty relaxed, pretty upbeat. Actually, there were people at the time said it was almost like a carnival atmosphere. People were quite jolly. They set off. By half past three, they're approaching the city centre. It is, of course, blocked off, sealed off by an army barricade on William Street. So at that point, most of the marches turned right going towards the bogside. They're going to stop when they get to free dairy corner.
气氛，与最初的预期相反，相当轻松，相当乐观。实际上，当时有人说这几乎像狂欢节的气氛。人们相当快乐。他们出发了。到三点半，他们接近市中心。当然，它被威廉街上的军队路障封锁、密封了。所以在那一点上，大多数游行者向右转，走向博格赛德。他们到达自由德里角时会停下来。
as it's called, the entrance to hear speeches, people denouncing internment. Now back at William Street by the barricade, blocking off the city centre, there are some scuffles between rioters and the paras. Teenagers basically throwing stones at the British Army. And this is where the first shots are fired. The paratroopers fire five rounds, and they wound a teenage boy and a 59-year-old man. But they don't kill anybody.
正如人们所称的那样，这是通往演讲现场的入口，人们在那里谴责拘留政策。现在回到威廉街的路障处，这里封锁了市中心，暴徒和伞兵之间发生了一些冲突。基本上是青少年在向英国军队投掷石块。就在这时，第一声枪响了。伞兵开了五枪，打伤了一名十几岁的男孩和一名59岁的男子。但他们没有杀死任何人。
But that is what they've basically in order to do. to wound to wound hooligans and rioters. And a few minutes later, there is a sniper shot. So he's an official IRA man. He fires a single shot. He misses the soldiers and he hits a drain pipe. So this is not long before 4 o'clock. A 355, Lieutenant Colonel Wilford asks permission from the commanding officer in Derry.
但这基本上就是他们被命令要做的事：打伤那些流氓和暴徒。几分钟后，传来了一声狙击手的枪响。那是一名官方爱尔兰共和军成员。他开了一枪，没打中士兵，而是打中了一根排水管。所以这发生在下午4点之前不久。3点55分，中校威尔福德向德里的指挥官请求许可。
He says, I wonder, can we send in the Paris to pick up yobbos? That's his phrase. and 12 minutes pass and then he gets the confirmation from the overall dairy commander as follows yes fine send in a para subunit
他说：“我想，我们能不能派伞兵去抓那些混混？”这是他的原话。12分钟过去了，他得到了德里总指挥官的确认，内容如下：“是的，可以，派出一支伞兵分队。”
to do scoop up op through barrier 14 not to conduct running battle down Rossville Street now this last sentence is totally ignored because a few minutes later
“去清理14号路障，而不是在罗斯维尔街进行追逐战。”现在，这最后一句被完全忽略了，因为几分钟后，
a convoy of armoured personnel carriers come screaming down the road down Rossville Street into the box side and paratroopers jump out and they immediately start grabbing people from the crowd, hitting them with kind of rifle butts, firing rubber bullets at this stage at them, and so on and so forth. And it's a scene, you've seen it so many times in this story in this series, the story of the troubles, chaos, hundreds of people screaming, people running away in panic, some people taking refuge
一队装甲运兵车尖叫着冲下街道，冲进博格赛德区，伞兵们跳下车，立即开始从人群中抓人，用步枪枪托殴打他们，在这个阶段还向他们发射橡胶子弹，诸如此类。这是一个场景，你在本系列关于“动乱”的故事中已经看过很多次了：混乱，数百人尖叫，人们惊慌失措地逃跑，有些人躲避
behind rubble barricades, throwing stones and things, but most people just running away. And the paras claimed later that it was at this point that they came under fire from snipers on top of the high-rise flats overlooking the scene. This, I think, the self-halt inquiry established beyond any possible doubt is just not true. There were no witnesses that saw snipers. There were no guns found. There were no bullets found afterwards. There was nothing. What effectively happens in the next few minutes is that the paratroopers completely lose control.
在瓦砾路障后面，投掷石块等杂物，但大多数人只是在逃跑。伞兵后来声称，正是在这一点上，他们遭到了俯瞰现场的高层公寓楼顶上的狙击手的射击。我认为，萨维尔调查已经毫无疑问地证实，这根本不是真的。没有目击者看到狙击手。没有发现枪支。事后也没有发现子弹。什么都没有。在接下来的几分钟里，实际上发生的是伞兵完全失去了控制。
I mean, it's not an unfamiliar story with people policing crowds. You know, it's a terrible story, but it's not unknown. Well, I suppose, I mean, the Vietnam comparison that Ted Kennedy made, is that kind of mili or something? Yeah. It's soldiers, frazzled on the edge, commit atrocities. Yeah. I mean, this is the funny thing about it.
我的意思是，这对于维持人群秩序的人来说并不是一个陌生的故事。你知道，这是一个可怕的故事，但并非闻所未闻。嗯，我想，泰德·肯尼迪所做的越南对比，那是某种军事上的吗？是的。这是士兵们在压力下崩溃，犯下暴行。是的，我的意思是，这就是关于这件事最讽刺的地方。
It costs 200 million pounds to do this inquiry. But I remember reading, you know, I was researching my book on the early 70s at that point when the report came. And I thought, you know, this is exactly as I thought it always would be. This would be the outcome. Because psychologically, from everything we know about how people behave in these situations, this makes complete sense. They sort of panic. They're over pumped up, as it were.
这项调查耗资2亿英镑。但我记得读过，你知道，当报告出来时，我正在研究关于70年代初的书。我想，你知道，这完全是我一直认为会有的结果。因为从心理学上讲，根据我们所知的人们在这种情况下如何表现的一切，这是完全合理的。他们有点恐慌。他们被过度刺激了，可以这么说。
They're very hard men. They're trained killers. They're also very young men. They lose control. They start shooting. They fire more than 100 rounds into the crowd. They hit 26 people and they kill 13 people. and most of the people they kill are very young.
他们是硬汉，是训练有素的杀手。他们也是非常年轻的人。他们失去了控制。他们开始射击。他们向人群发射了100多发子弹。他们击中了26人，杀死了13人。而且他们杀死的大多数人非常年轻。
Six of them of the 13 were 17 years old. Most of the people they kill were running away, running to safety. Some of them were trying to help the injured, but we know that a lot of them were shot in the back. And the most famous image of the day is a Catholic priest called Edward Daly, and you can see the photos online. It's one of the ones that comes up immediately if you Google Bloody Sunday. It's a priest, and he's waving a blood-stained handkerchief as a white flag.
13人中有6人是17岁。他们杀死的大多数人当时正在逃跑，奔向安全地带。有些人试图帮助伤者，但我们知道他们中有许多人是背部中弹。那天最著名的照片是一位名叫爱德华·戴利的罗马天主教神父，你可以在网上看到这些照片。如果你谷歌“血腥星期日”，它会立即跳出来。照片里是一位神父，他挥舞着沾满血迹的手帕作为白旗。
and they're trying to carry this guy to safety, 17-year-old Jackie Duddy. And Duddy dies just moments later. The priest, Edward Daly, was holding his hand and giving him the last rights as he died. And as you said, why this all happened is quite a straightforward. I think question to answer. If you send trained killers, renowned for their aggression, to police a march. And if you tell them, you're going to be attacked by snipers, you're making it quite likely that they will lose control.
他们正试图把这个家伙抬到安全地带，17岁的杰基·杜迪。杜迪在几分钟后就去世了。神父爱德华·戴利握着他的手，在他临终时为他做了临终祈祷。正如你所说，这一切为什么会发生，我认为是一个相当直截了当的问题。如果你派遣以侵略性著称的训练有素的杀手去维持游行秩序，并且如果你告诉他们“你们会遭到狙击手的袭击”，那么他们失去控制的可能性就非常大。
So this is, I mean, General Ford had actually said it himself. That's why I read the quotation out. He'd said it in December. The risk of casualties is high. So-called unarmed rioters possibly teenagers are certain to be shot. Much will be made of the invasion of dairy and the slaughter of the innocent. Now, did the Paris feel guilty after this had happened? The short answer is no.
所以，我的意思是，福特将军自己其实也说过。这就是我读出那段引文的原因。他在12月就说过。伤亡风险很高。所谓的非武装暴徒，可能是青少年，肯定会被射杀。关于入侵德里和屠杀无辜者的言论将会很多。那么，伞兵在事后感到内疚吗？简短的回答是：没有。
One of them says in the Brits that I mentioned, he says, we saw it as a job well done. I mean, this is possibly a heretical question. Yeah. Bearing in mind the military situation, was it a job well done? In other words, did it serve as a salutary atrocity
其中一个人在提到的英国人中说，我们认为这是一项完成得很好的工作。我的意思是，这可能是一个异端的问题。是的。考虑到当时的军事局势，这是一项完成得很好的工作吗？换句话说，它是否起到了一种警示性的暴行作用，
which made people think twice? No, absolutely not. If you're going to take such a cold-blooded view of it, which I mean, it's not a fair question to ask, right? Yeah, it's the rich of the third, you know, they did it and they right to do it kind of thing. Absolutely not, because, I mean, the evidence is in what happens in the next 11 months in Northern Ireland, and indeed in the next 20-odd years, which is things got a lot worse, and it complete, as we'll see, it completely destroys the reputation of the British Army and corrods beyond measure the relationship between them and much of the local population. So absolutely not. If you were taking the most Machiavellian kind of possibly or Klausovitzian interpretation, then no, absolutely not at all.
让人们三思而后行？不，绝对不是。如果你要采取如此冷血的观点，我的意思是，这不是一个公平的问题，对吧？是的，这是那种“他们做了，他们做得对”之类的说法。绝对不是，因为证据就在接下来的11个月里北爱尔兰发生的事情中，实际上在接下来的20多年里也是如此，那就是情况变得更糟了，正如我们将看到的，它彻底摧毁了英国军队的声誉，并极大地腐蚀了他们与当地大部分民众之间的关系。所以绝对不是。如果你采取最马基雅维利式或克劳塞维茨式的解释，那么不，绝对不是。
And what happens to free dairy? Still there. Do they not go in and bulldoze it? No, not at this point. No. That happens much later, think of Operation Moteman, but not at this point. No. Just on the Paris, actually, the job well done thing.
那么“自由德里”发生了什么？还在那里。他们没有进去推平它吗？不，不是在这个时候。不。那发生在很久以后，想想“莫特曼行动”，但不是现在。不。只是关于伞兵，关于“工作完成得很好”那件事。
I guess to the end of their lives, a lot of the powers, I mean, they maintained and presumably still maintain that they did the right thing. They were shooting in self-defense. And actually, a really interesting person who's written about this, a very unexpected person is the extremely right-wing journalist. Douglas Murray. So Douglas Murray went, you know, assistant editor of the spectator or associate editor of spectator. He went to the Saville Inquiry and wrote a book about it. And he is incredibly scathing about the paratroopers. He calls them unrelenting liars. He says, you know,
我想直到他们生命的尽头，许多伞兵，我的意思是，他们坚持并且大概仍然坚持他们做了正确的事。他们是在自卫射击。实际上，一个写过这件事的非常有趣的人，一个非常出人意料的人，是极右翼记者道格拉斯·默里。所以道格拉斯·默里，你知道，《旁观者》的助理编辑或副编辑。他去了萨维尔调查现场并写了一本书。他对伞兵的评价极其尖刻。他称他们为“无情的骗子”。他说，你知道，
they lied and lied and lied about coming under attack, about what they did, about not shooting people in the back, all of this kind of thing. They perjured themselves in the Saval Inquiry. I wonder if that's quite right. I think it's quite possible, in fact, psychologically very plausible, that they made up excuses and then came to believe them. I mean, isn't that such a common thing that people do? Also, I suppose, you know, your subconscious could tell you that you're hearing things that prompt you to do something that you want to do anyway. In the heat of the moment, in the chaos, people screaming, running away, sounds of gunshots, sounds of, you know, battle, you might come to, believe, you know, you might think, you might assume you're under fire because you've been
他们撒谎，撒谎，又撒谎，关于遭到袭击，关于他们做了什么，关于没有从背后射击人，所有这些事情。他们在萨维尔调查中作了伪证。我不知道这是否完全正确。我认为很有可能，事实上在心理上非常合理，他们编造了借口，然后开始相信它们。我的意思是，这不是人们常做的事情吗？此外，我想，你的潜意识可能会告诉你，你听到的事情促使你去做你无论如何都想做的事情。在激烈的时刻，在混乱中，人们尖叫，逃跑，枪声，战斗的声音，你可能会开始相信，你知道，你可能会认为，你可能会假设你正在受到攻击，因为你被
told it's possible, and then you start shooting, and then you lose control over yourself. Wilford is furious, isn't he, that Blair sets up the inquiry. Yes. Even if he's got a ponytail by that point. Yeah, from his Belgian antique shop, he's absolutely outraged. As indeed were, not everybody. So if you go, look into this, you can find plenty of people in the army who say it's terrible that our brave boys were subject.
告知这是可能的，然后你开始射击，然后你失去了对自己的控制。威尔福德很愤怒，不是吗，因为布莱尔发起了调查。是的。即使他那时已经留了马尾辫。是的，从他的比利时古董店里，他绝对是愤怒的。确实如此，并不是每个人都这样。所以如果你去调查这件事，你可以在军队里找到很多人说，我们的勇敢小伙子受到这种无情的调查是可怕的。
to this relentless investigation. You know, they're in a terrible situation, terrible pressure, leave them alone. Equally, you can find people in the army who say they were out of control. I knew they were out of control. Well, because it's a terrible state on the reputation of the British Army.
他们处于可怕的境地，可怕的压力下，别管他们。同样，你也可以在军队里找到人说他们失控了。我知道他们失控了。嗯，因为这对英国军队的声誉来说是一个可怕的状态。
So, I mean, as Cameron says, you know, it's unjustified and unjustifiable. Right. Cameron said that, but that's not what British politicians said at the time. So at the time, the government line was that the Paris had fired and self-defense and they were tremendous fellows. So Reginald Maudling the next day gave a speech in the Commons. He didn't say a single word about the 13 victims.
所以，我的意思是，正如卡梅伦所说，你知道，这是不公正且无法辩解的。对。卡梅伦是这么说的，但那不是当时英国政客所说的。所以当时，政府的口径是伞兵是在自卫，他们是了不起的家伙。所以雷金纳德·莫德林第二天在下议院发表了演讲。他没有对13名受害者说一个字。
He said the paratroopers were defending themselves from people attacking them with firearms and with bombs, which just was not true. And actually, Bernadette Devlin, remember her? Yeah, they're the MP. She physically attacked Maudling on the floor of the House of Commons. Extraordinary things. She basically came down and basically just laid into him because she was. was so upset that he was, you know, these people had been killed and then she saw it, he was
他说伞兵是在保护自己免受那些用枪支和炸弹攻击他们的人的伤害，这根本不是真的。实际上，伯纳黛特·德夫林，还记得她吗？是的，那位议员。她在下议院地板上对莫德林进行了身体攻击。非同寻常的事情。她基本上走下来，直接对他动手，因为她太难过了，因为他，你知道，这些人被杀了，然后她看到他正在
smearing the victims. But actually, Mordling's constituency agent wrote to him afterwards and said, while it is never pleasant when people are shot dead, I must say I'm glad that at long last the troops have started to get tough. And you see that a lot in the British press in the next few days, the Daily Mail. Our troops are doing an impossible job, impossibly well. Even the guardian. The Guardian. The army has an intolerably difficult time in Ireland at times it is bound to act firmly, even severely. Robustly, one might say. Robustly, exactly. And of course, a lot of unionists, well, certainly loyalists said the more hardline unionists in Northern Ireland are not terribly sad about it. So Time magazine interviewed a labourer in a Belfast pub who said, you know, after 13 people
抹黑受害者。但实际上，莫德林的选区代理人后来写信给他，说：“虽然人们被枪杀从来都不是一件令人愉快的事，但我必须说，我很高兴军队终于开始采取强硬手段了。”你在接下来的几天里在英国媒体上经常看到这一点，《每日邮报》：“我们的军队正在做一项不可能完成的工作，完成得好得不可思议。”甚至《卫报》也是如此。《卫报》：“军队在爱尔兰面临着极其困难的时期，有时它必然会采取坚定甚至严厉的行动。”“强硬地”，人们可能会说。强硬地，没错。当然，许多统一派，嗯，当然是效忠派，在北爱尔兰的强硬派统一派对这件事并不感到特别难过。《时代》杂志采访了贝尔法斯特一家酒吧的一名工人，他说，你知道，在13个人
had been shot dead, he said, I wish it had been 1,300 of the bastards. But, of course it's terrible for Britain's image in Ireland and in America. In Ireland, there was a national day of morning, there was huge demonstrations, this massive crowd assembled outside the British embassy in Dublin, the police tried to hold them back, the crowd started throwing petrol bombs, and finally they burned down the Chancery Building. You know, it's kind of pretty big deal in a capital where basically nothing ever happens. And the big winners from all this, I mean, you're asking, you know, what are the, if you're being sort of completely ruthless about it, what are the implications? Well, the big winners from this are not the British, they're not the unionists, they are the
被枪杀后，他说：“我希望是那1300个混蛋。”但是，这当然对英国在爱尔兰和美国的形象很糟糕。在爱尔兰，举行了全国哀悼日，有巨大的示威活动，这群庞大的人群聚集在都柏林英国大使馆外，警察试图阻拦他们，人群开始投掷汽油弹，最后他们烧毁了大法官大楼。你知道，在一个基本上什么都不会发生的首都，这算是一件大事。而这一切的最大赢家，我的意思是，你在问，你知道，如果我们要完全冷酷地看待它，后果是什么？嗯，这的最大赢家不是英国人，不是统一派，而是
provisional IRA. So it's not a turning point, but it accelerates a process that's already underway, the breakdown and the legitimacy of the government, the collapse of the relationship between the British and the Catholics, and Republican paramilitary recruitment. Because basically, imagine that you're, let us say you're a middle class Catholic, you know, who's not terribly sectarian, and, you know, you're of a moderate disposition. You look at this story, and this story seems to say to you, everything that people say about the British is true. They're murderers, and then they lie about it. And you could think about the impact of people of Irish descent in Britain. So you could think of a man who is the son of Irish ancestors.
临时爱尔兰共和军。所以这不是一个转折点，但它加速了一个已经在进行的过程，即政府合法性的崩溃，英国人和天主教徒之间关系的破裂，以及共和派准军事组织的招募。因为基本上，想象一下你是一个中产阶级天主教徒，你知道，不是特别宗派主义，而且，你知道，你是温和派。你看着这个故事，这个故事似乎在告诉你，人们关于英国人所说的一切都是真的。他们是杀人犯，然后他们对此撒谎。你可以想想这对英国爱尔兰裔人的影响。所以你可以想到一个爱尔兰祖先的后代，
Irish forebears, had a very successful career, never said or sung anything political, really, and forms a new band and releases Give Ireland Back to the Irish. Because it's Paul McCartney. I was hoping it was Dennis Healy, but it wasn't. It was Paul McCartney. Paul McCartney, that is when he releases that single in the wake of Bloody Sunday. So to quote one young man, another young man, Events that day probably led more young nationalists to join the provisionals than any other single action by the British.
有爱尔兰血统，事业非常成功，从未说过或唱过任何政治内容，真的，然后组建了一个新乐队并发行了《把爱尔兰还给爱尔兰人》。因为那是保罗·麦卡特尼。我本来希望是丹尼斯·希利，但不是。是保罗·麦卡特尼。保罗·麦卡特尼，那就是他在血腥星期日之后发行那张单曲的时候。所以引用一位年轻人的话，另一位年轻人：“那天发生的事件可能导致比英国采取的任何其他单一行动都更多的年轻民族主义者加入了临时派。”
From that day on, money, guns and recruits flooded into the IRA. And the name of that young man was Jerry Adams. And we will be hearing more about him after the break. This episode is brought to you by Amazon. Tom throughout history change has often been driven by businesses and institutions that end up having a massive impact on society as a whole. And there's probably no better example than the Ford Motor Company. Henry Ford and his managers revolutionized production through their pioneering assembly lines. And they influenced factories and working practices in countries all over the world.
从那天起，金钱、枪支和新兵涌入了爱尔兰共和军。那个年轻人的名字叫杰里·亚当斯。休息后我们将听到更多关于他的消息。本集由亚马逊赞助。汤姆，纵观历史，变革往往是由最终对整个社会产生巨大影响的企业和机构推动的。可能没有比福特汽车公司更好的例子了。亨利·福特和他的经理们通过开创性的装配线彻底改变了生产。他们影响了世界各地的工厂和工作实践。
Another example of a business driving technological and social change is Amazon, which is increasing the number of its electric vehicles used for delivery, in Europe to over 10,000 by the end of this year, 2026. Now, on top of that, over 50% of Amazon deliveries now come with less packaging, or sometimes no added packaging at all. It helps to avoid unnecessary waste, and it makes recycling at home that much easier. Find out more at amazon.com.uk slash sustainability. Two and five Canadians will hear the words you have cancer. That's why every step and dollar raised matters.
另一个推动技术和社会变革的企业例子是亚马逊，到2026年底，它在欧洲用于配送的电动汽车数量将增加到超过10,000辆。此外，超过50%的亚马逊包裹现在包装更少，有时甚至根本没有额外包装。这有助于避免不必要的浪费，并使家庭回收变得更加容易。在amazon.com.uk/sustainability了解更多信息。五分之二的加拿大人会听到“你得了癌症”这句话。这就是为什么每一步和筹集的每一美元都很重要。
On September 19th, join thousands in Toronto for the Princess Margaret Cancer Foundation Walk. Challenge yourself, friends, and family to walk 21 kilometers in support of life-saving research. Together, we can carry the fire and help create a world free from the fear of cancer. Register today at pmcf walk. Real Canadian Superstore has everything you need this back-to-school season. Save on lunchbox savers like Ziggy's sliced deli-meat products for always 375. And get Life Brand Pure Vita shampoo or conditioner for $8 each. At Real Canadian Superstore, when you're ready, we're ready, with a whole world and more.
9月19日，加入多伦多的数千人参加玛格丽特公主癌症基金会步行活动。挑战你自己、朋友和家人步行21公里，以支持挽救生命的癌症研究。我们可以一起传递火炬，帮助创造一个没有癌症恐惧的世界。今天就在pmcf walk注册。Real Canadian Superstore有你这个返校季所需的一切。购买Ziggy's切片熟食肉类产品等午餐盒必备品，价格始终为3.75。并以每件8美元的价格购买Life Brand Pure Vita洗发水或护发素。在Real Canadian Superstore，当你准备好了，我们就准备好了，提供一个完整的世界及更多。
Hello everyone and welcome back to The Rest is History. It is now February 1972 and Northern Ireland is reeling from the shocking events of Bloody Sunday, which happened on the 30th of January 1972. And I guess, Dominant, I mean, the massive, massive question is where does the province go from here? Yeah, so it's pretty clear,
大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。现在是1972年2月，北爱尔兰正从1972年1月30日发生的血腥星期日的震惊事件中恢复过来。我想，多米尼克，我的意思是，一个巨大的、巨大的问题是，这个省从这里走向何方？是的，所以很清楚，
I think, that Stormont Parliament is doomed. I think it's probably been doomed for a couple of years, certainly from the introduction of British troops. I think it was always on borrowed time. But what happens next is far from settled. The classic idea that Irish Republicans have that the British are desperate to cling on,
我认为，斯托蒙特议会注定要失败。我认为它可能已经注定失败了几年，当然是从英国军队进入开始。我认为它一直是在借来的时间里运作。但接下来会发生什么远未确定。爱尔兰共和派所持有的那种认为英国人拼命想抓住
to Northern Ireland is a fallacy. Actually, as we've discussed, a lot of the public are sick of it and a lot of the politicians would love to pull out. So in February 72, Heath and his cabinet have a big chat about it. And it's remarkable. All options are on the table. They talk about redrawing the border, let the Catholic areas join the Republic. We could have a referendum on ending partition. Maybe there's a solution where Northern Ireland remains technically part of the United Kingdom, but has some sort of constitutional association with Ireland. I mean, that is kind of the solution that ultimately they get to, isn't it? Yes, that is where they get to.
北爱尔兰不放的经典观点是一个谬论。实际上，正如我们所讨论的，很多公众对此感到厌倦，很多政客很乐意撤出。所以在72年2月，希思和他的内阁对此进行了深入讨论。这很了不起。所有选项都在桌面上。他们谈论重新划分边界，让天主教地区加入共和国。我们可以就结束分裂举行公投。也许有一个解决方案，北爱尔兰在技术上仍然是联合王国的一部分，但与爱尔兰有某种宪法联系。我的意思是，这正是他们最终达到的解决方案，不是吗？是的，这就是他们达到的地方。
And actually a point worth making, I think, the place where they get to, the British would have taken that at any point after about 1970. It's absolutely, I mean, I know we joke about being a patriotic podcast, so some people will say, oh, they're very biased or whatever. But frankly, when you look at the history of it, it's not British obstinacy that stops the peace process happening in the 1970s. It's that of other parties. The British would absolutely have taken something like the Good Friday Agreement in 1972,
实际上，我认为值得指出的一点是，他们达到的那个地方，英国人在1970年左右的任何时候都会接受。这绝对是，我的意思是，我知道我们开玩笑说这是一个爱国播客，所以有些人会说，哦，他们非常偏颇之类的。但坦率地说，当你审视它的历史时，阻止和平进程在70年代发生的并不是英国的固执。而是其他各方的固执。英国绝对会在1972年接受像《贝尔法斯特协议》那样的东西，
and they would have done all the way through, I think. And in fact, Ted Heath's Foreign Secretary, Sir Alec Douglas Hume, is on the right of the Tory party at this meeting, basically says our interests would best be served by getting rid. Tell the unionists they should join a United Ireland. You know, the fact that somebody like that is taking that position, would have come as a shock, I think, to a lot of Britain's critics because there's an assumption that people in Britain, I don't know, they're sort of a misty-eyed attachment
而且我认为他们会一直这样做。事实上，泰德·希思的外交大臣亚历克·道格拉斯-休姆爵士在这次会议上站在保守党的右翼，基本上说我们的利益最好通过摆脱它来得到满足。告诉统一派他们应该加入一个统一的爱尔兰。你知道，像那样的人采取这种立场的事实，我认为会让很多英国的批评者感到震惊，因为有一种假设认为英国人，我不知道，他们对
to the possession in Northern Ireland, which is just not true at all. Well, that's the thing, isn't it, that both the loyalist and the nationalist paramilitaries, they have a stake in committing violence. The British Army, despite running amok on Bloody Sunday, don't feel strongly committed enough to an ideological position to do anything comparable to that.
北爱尔兰的占有有一种朦胧的依恋，这根本不是真的。嗯，这就是问题所在，不是吗，效忠派和民族主义准军事组织，他们都有参与暴力的利害关系。英国军队，尽管在血腥星期日横冲直撞，但并没有感到对某种意识形态立场有足够的强烈承诺去做任何与之相当的事情。
They'd much rather just pull out. They would. No question they would. Basically, I think if you're in the army, you're told you're being posted to Northern Ireland, you don't think, brilliant, you know, let's get stuck in, you think, oh, no, really? Anyway, in Northern Ireland itself, the pace of events now is quickening.
他们宁愿直接撤出。他们会的。毫无疑问他们会的。基本上，我认为如果你在军队里，你被告知你被派往北爱尔兰，你不会想“太棒了，让我们投入进去”，你会想“哦，不，真的吗？”无论如何，在北爱尔兰本身，事件的节奏现在正在加快。
So the rate of killing increases in February 1972, the IRA alone killed 17 civilians. And then on the 23rd of February you have news from England. The official IRA have detonated a car bomb at the paratroopers' headquarters in Aldershot by the officers' mess. The troops were away, so the car bomb killed seven people. These people were, respectively, five dinner ladies, a Catholic chaplain and the gardener at the barracks. And is this the first attack on British soil? Well, it's English soil, isn't it?
所以杀戮率在1972年2月增加，仅爱尔兰共和军就杀死了17名平民。然后在2月23日，你从英国得到了消息。官方爱尔兰共和军在奥尔德肖特的伞兵总部军官食堂旁引爆了一枚汽车炸弹。部队当时不在，所以汽车炸弹杀死了7人。这些人分别是五名食堂女工、一名天主教牧师和军营的园丁。这是对英国本土的第一次袭击吗？嗯，那是英格兰的土地，不是吗？
because it tends to be England that gets attacked. Yes. Because that seems the obvious tactic. And it's surprising that they don't do it earlier, really. Well, don't forget they had attacked British soil in the 30s at Coventry in 1939. But it's, you know, I suppose they've got limited resources and they want to win the war on the streets of Belfast initially. It's not really until 1974, 75 that they move in earnest to attacking Britain. But yeah, it is the first sign of something that will.
因为往往是英格兰受到攻击。是的。因为这似乎是显而易见的策略。令人惊讶的是他们没有早点这样做，真的。嗯，别忘了他们在30年代的1939年袭击过英国本土。但，你知道，我想他们的资源有限，他们最初想在贝尔法斯特的街头赢得战争。直到1974年、75年，他们才真正开始认真地攻击英国。但是的，这是某种将要发生的事情的第一个迹象。
recur very ominously. So that was the official IRA. Two weeks later, an attack by the provisional IRA this time in Belfast. And this, the target this time, I mean, this is a truly awful story. The target is the Abercorn restaurant in Belfast City Centre. So it was Catholic owned. But the reason they attacked it was probably because the upstairs bar of the Abercorn was very popular with soldiers on their evenings off. And the bombers were probably two teenage girls, because people saw two teenage girls leaving a handbag. But the result is a horrendous scene. So it was a Saturday afternoon.
非常不祥地重演。所以那是官方爱尔兰共和军。两周后，这次是临时爱尔兰共和军在贝尔法斯特发动的袭击。这次的目标，我的意思是，这是一个真正可怕的故事。目标是贝尔法斯特市中心的阿伯康餐厅。所以它是天主教徒拥有的。但他们袭击它的原因可能是因为阿伯康楼上的酒吧在士兵下班后的晚上非常受欢迎。炸弹袭击者可能是两名十几岁的女孩，因为人们看到两名十几岁的女孩留下了一个手提包。但结果是一个可怕的场景。所以那是一个周六下午。
The restaurant was packed with shoppers, mainly women, having coffee. Two women in their early 20s were killed. They were both Catholics. 140 people were injured. I mean, some horrible stories. A woman who had been out shopping for her wedding dress, lost an arm and an eye. A paramedic afterwards said the ambulances were awashed with blood.
餐厅里挤满了购物者，主要是喝咖啡的女性。两名20出头的女性被杀。她们都是天主教徒。140人受伤。我的意思是，一些可怕的故事。一个出去买婚纱的女人失去了一只手臂和一只眼睛。一名护理人员事后说，救护车上到处都是血。
It was the most distressing scene I've ever witnessed. And now here's the horrible twist. They call in all the doctors, you know, it's an emergency. So many people injured. One of the doctors who came in was an anesthetist called Dr. Fred Boreen. And he worked through the night on the wounded. And when he'd finished, he was taken aside and told, one of the two women killed was your daughter, Janet.
这是我见过的最令人痛苦的场景。现在这里有一个可怕的转折。他们召集了所有的医生，你知道，这是一个紧急情况。这么多人受伤。其中一名赶来的医生是一位名叫弗雷德·博林博士的麻醉师。他整晚都在为伤者工作。当他完成工作时，他被拉到一边，被告知，被杀的两名女性之一是你的女儿，珍妮特。
I mean, just unbelievable. So you've got a sense now that things are really becoming unglued. And actually, I was listening to some BBC radio. radio reports. They went to Voxpops on the streets of Belfast and the results are absolutely blood curdling because people on both sides basically say, yeah, maybe the British should get out because then we can just crack on and have the civil war. So it's a Catholic man.
我的意思是，简直令人难以置信。所以你现在感觉到事情真的开始分崩离析了。实际上，我当时正在听一些BBC广播。广播报道。他们去了贝尔法斯特街头的街头采访，结果绝对是令人毛骨悚然的，因为双方的人基本上都说，是的，也许英国人应该离开，因为那样我们就可以直接开始进行内战了。所以这是一个天主教男人。
He says, once they go, we'll have a proper civil war. The army of the Republic will probably intervene and help us, which is deluded, I think. Mr. Lynch won't let us down, he says, they barely have an army, exactly. Then there's an elderly, I mean, this is the one that always sticks in my mind. an elderly Protestant housewife, she says, yes, the British won't stay
他说，一旦他们走了，我们将有一场真正的内战。共和国的军队可能会干预并帮助我们，我认为这是被误导了。林奇先生不会让我们失望的，他说，他们几乎没有军队，完全正确。然后有一位年长的，我的意思是，这是我脑海中一直挥之不去的一个。一位年长的基督教家庭主妇，她说，是的，英国人不会留下来，
because the British is soft. You know, they're, you can't rely on the British. They're still thinking that after Bloody Sunday. But I think there were a lot of people
因为英国人很软弱。你知道，他们，你不能依赖英国人。他们在血腥星期日之后仍然那样想。但我认为有很多人
who thought, remember that guy who said, why couldn't you shop 1,300 rather than 13? Yeah, I suppose. And this old woman says, when the British leave, she says,
认为，记得那个说“为什么不能射杀1300个而不是13个”的家伙吗？是的，我想。而这位老妇人说，当英国人离开时，她说，
we will have to fight with our bare hands. Shocking. And I think what is interesting about this, the reason I wanted to bring it up was the common view is so often that this
我们将不得不赤手空拳地战斗。令人震惊。我认为这很有趣，我想提出它的原因是，常见的观点往往是，这
is a conflict that is imposed on a great mass of peace-loving people by just a tiny minority of monsters. And of course, there are a lot of people who want peace. And most people in Northern Ireland never set off a bomb, never pick up a gun. It would be a gross calumny to accuse them of all being suffused with sectarian hatred. But the paramilitaries are successful because they fill a political need, because they do have support. And does it? And does it? And does it? And does, that mean that people who are proactively for accommodation with the other side are targets? They're not targets, but they are, they find life, sometimes they find life very difficult. We will meet one such person at the very end of this episode, a very sad story.
是一场由一小撮怪物强加给一大群热爱和平的人的冲突。当然，有很多人想要和平。北爱尔兰的大多数人从未引爆过炸弹，从未拿起过枪。指责他们所有人都充满了宗派仇恨将是一种严重的诽谤。但准军事组织之所以成功，是因为他们满足了一种政治需求，因为他们确实有支持。这是否意味着那些积极寻求与另一方和解的人是目标？他们不是目标，但他们发现生活，有时他们发现生活非常困难。我们将在本集结束时见到这样一个人，一个非常悲伤的故事。
Yes, I mean, actually, is not Terrence O'Neill, a good example of that? Yes, I suppose. You know, his premiership destroyed because he basically was regarded by, you know, his base, as an appeaser. Kevin Myers in his memoir says you know, politicians always spoke about a tiny minority of terrorists but he's very caustic.
是的，我的意思是，实际上，特伦斯·奥尼尔不是一个很好的例子吗？是的，我想。你知道，他的总理职位被摧毁了，因为他基本上被他的基础视为一个绥靖者。凯文·迈尔斯在他的回忆录中说，你知道，政客们总是谈论一小撮恐怖分子，但他非常尖刻。
He said, you know, for every active terrorist, there was probably a support group of at least 50 non-terrorists. Now, of course, that's not everybody, but, you know, this is a politically very polarized society in which a lot of people are prepared to make excuses for their own side. And that's not, I don't mean, this is nothing
他说，你知道，对于每一个活跃的恐怖分子，可能都有一个至少50人的非恐怖分子支持小组。现在，当然，那不是每个人，但，你知道，这是一个政治上非常两极分化的社会，很多人准备为自己的一方找借口。这并不是，我的意思是，这没有什么
uniquely Northern Irish about this. This is so often the case. So Heath is watching all this in horror. Then he gets the final straw, which is on 20th of March, the first really major IRA car bomb, because previously they'd been bombs in parcels and things. This was in Lower Donny Gould Street in the city centre, and midday. The street was full of shoppers and also schoolchildren going home for lunch. The IRA, as was often their way, they telephoned a warning, but they did so so late that it was impossible to act efficiently upon it. And they gave the wrong street name anyway in the warning.
北爱尔兰独特之处。这种情况经常发生。所以希思惊恐地看着这一切。然后他得到了最后一根稻草，即3月20日，第一次真正重大的爱尔兰共和军汽车炸弹，因为之前他们都是包裹炸弹之类的。这是在市中心的下多尼戈尔街，中午。街道上挤满了购物者，还有回家吃午饭的学童。爱尔兰共和军，像他们往常的方式一样，打了一个警告电话，但他们打得太晚了，以至于不可能有效地采取行动。而且他们在警告中给出了错误的街道名称。
Bonn went off, it killed seven people, including two policemen who were examining the car and three bin men who were working in the road. A horrific scene. I mean, when you read reports of it, you know, I have to sort of, I don't want to kind of give all the quotations because they're so horrible. The carnage, the school children injured, glass everywhere, body parts everywhere, it's awful. So two days after this, Fultner is summoned to London and he finds Heath completely grim faced and kind of curt and he says, okay, enough now. This cannot go on. This is the end. You've
炸弹爆炸了，杀死了7人，包括两名正在检查汽车的警察和三名正在路上工作的清洁工。一个可怕的场景。我的意思是，当你阅读关于它的报道时，你知道，我不得不，我不想给出所有的引文，因为它们太可怕了。大屠杀，受伤的学童，到处都是玻璃，到处都是身体部位，太可怕了。所以在这件事发生两天后，福克纳被传唤到伦敦，他发现希思脸色阴沉，态度生硬，他说，好吧，现在够了。这不能再继续下去了。这是终点。你
got two options. Number one, you continue as Prime Minister in Northern Ireland, but we will run law and order for you. You lose responsibility for law and order. We're going to get rid of internment. We're going to have a new vote on the Irish border. And you have to invite moderate nationalists into your coalition government. That's option one. And option two, if you don't take that we're going to shut you down shut down the northern Irish parliament we will rule you directly from Westminster and Fultner cannot
有两个选择。第一，你继续担任北爱尔兰总理，但我们将为你管理法律和秩序。你失去对法律和秩序的责任。我们要摆脱拘留。我们将就爱尔兰边界进行新的投票。你必须邀请温和的民族主义者加入你的联合政府。这是选项一。选项二，如果你不接受，我们将关闭你，关闭北爱尔兰议会，我们将直接从威斯敏斯特统治你们，而福克纳不能
I mean it's amazing that he didn't see this coming he cannot believe it he's completely taken aback they have a nine hour argument about it he says to Heath I thought you were my friend I feel betrayed by you he's also very offended he says to Heath at one point you're treating the parliament to Northern Ireland like a glorified county council and Heath with his legendary tact and charge
我的意思是，令人惊讶的是他没有预见到这一点，他完全被惊呆了。他们为此争论了九个小时。他对希思说，我以为你是我的朋友，我觉得被你背叛了。他也感到非常被冒犯，他在某个时候对希思说，你把北爱尔兰议会当作一个美化的县议会来对待，而希思以他传奇般的机智和
arm says, well, you are. Yeah, exactly. So Fultner goes back to Belfast. When he gets to Belfast, of course there's been another bomb. A bomb by the railway station destroys much of the railway station and injured 17 people in the Europa Hotel next door. So the next morning, Faulkner rings Heath and he says, I'm out, I'm done. You know, I'm not going to do what you tell me.
傲慢说，嗯，你确实是。是的，完全正确。所以福克纳回到贝尔法斯特。当他到达贝尔法斯特时，当然又发生了一次炸弹袭击。火车站的一枚炸弹摧毁了大部分火车站，并炸伤了隔壁欧罗巴酒店的17人。所以第二天早上，福克纳打电话给希思，他说，我退出了，我完了。你知道，我不会做你告诉我的事。
And so the following day, the 24th of March, Heath goes on TV across the United Kingdom. Heath, by the way, I mean, one thing we haven't really captured, Heath is absolutely shattered because you talked about the concatenation of events, I think last time. Heath has just been battling to get European entry through the House of Commons, and he's just been humiliated by the 1972 minor strike. I mean, Heath has basically had like an hour's sleep in the last six months. Well, I wonder he's rude.
所以第二天，3月24日，希思在整个联合王国的电视上发表讲话。希思，顺便说一句，我的意思是，我们还没有真正捕捉到的一件事，希思完全崩溃了，因为你上次谈到了事件的连锁反应，我想。希思一直在努力通过下议院获得欧洲准入权，并且刚刚被1972年的矿工罢工羞辱了。我的意思是，希思在过去六个月里基本上只睡了一个小时。嗯，我怀疑他很粗鲁。
Yeah. Well, he's very rude. I mean, to be fair, he'd be rude anyway. So he looks on TV, he looks grey and straight. He says, obviously Stormwater hasn't worked with shutting it down. I am sending my lieutenant, Willie Whitelaw, more of whom later, to Belfast, as Secretary of State for Northern Ireland. He's basically going to be the Imperial Pro-Consul in Northern Ireland. And Heath tries to end on a jolly note.
是的。嗯，他非常粗鲁。我的意思是，公平地说，他无论如何都会很粗鲁。所以他在电视上看起来灰暗而僵硬。他说，显然斯托蒙特没有奏效，我们要关闭它。我正在派遣我的副手威利·怀特劳，稍后会详细介绍他，去贝尔法斯特，担任北爱尔兰国务大臣。他基本上将成为北爱尔兰的帝国总督。希思试图以愉快的语气结束。
This is a chance at last to bring the bombings and killings to an end. But nobody in Northern Ireland sees it that way. Do you think Heath sees it that way? No, I don't think Heath. Of course, Heath doesn't see it that way. he's not an idiot. He's just saying it because you can't end on a downbeat note and say, we're all doomed, everything's awful, nothing's going to get better.
这是最后一次结束爆炸和杀戮的机会。但北爱尔兰没有人那样看。你认为希思那样看吗？不，我不认为希思。当然，希思不那样看。他不是白痴。他只是那样说，因为你不能以低调的语气结束，说“我们都完了，一切都很糟糕，什么都不会好转”。
So basically everybody in Northern Ireland condemns it. The IRA said the war goes on now. Brilliant. The gloves are off. We're fighting the British. Faulkner gives a press conference and says this is a victory for those who shout, lie, denigrate and destroy it, shows that violence can pay. I mean, he's not wrong about that.
所以基本上北爱尔兰的每个人都谴责它。爱尔兰共和军说战争现在继续。太棒了。手套脱掉了。我们正在与英国人作战。福克纳举行新闻发布会说，这是那些大喊大叫、撒谎、诋毁和破坏的人的胜利，这表明暴力可以带来回报。我的意思是，他关于这一点并没有错。
No, I mean, I guess he isn't wrong. Absolutely he's not wrong. The shipyard workers at Harland and Wolf, descendants of the men who've built the Titanic. They walk out, they march through Belfast, chanting against Heath, the IRA and the Catholic Church. Goodness, what a Trinity there. And, yeah, Ted Heath is kind of odd in that company, isn't he?
不，我的意思是，我想他没有错。他绝对没有错。哈兰德和沃尔夫造船厂的工人们，那些建造泰坦尼克号的人的后代。他们走出来，游行穿过贝尔法斯特，高呼反对希思、爱尔兰共和军和天主教会。天哪，那是什么三位一体。而且，是的，泰德·希思在那个群体中有点奇怪，不是吗？
He's the odd one now. He's a very Anglican-looking man. He's not a Catholic. Although he does like Europe. So he hangs around with a load of European Catholics. And there's a huge demonstration outside Stormont, 100,000 people with Ulster flags and Orange Orders. of flags and all this kind of thing.
他现在是奇怪的一个。他是一个看起来非常圣公会的人。他不是天主教徒。虽然他确实喜欢欧洲。所以他和一群欧洲天主教徒混在一起。斯托蒙特外有巨大的示威活动，10万人挥舞着阿尔斯特旗帜和奥兰治勋章的旗帜，所有这些东西。
So he's Lieutenant Willie Whitelaw flies into Belfast. We met him in the Thatcher episode. We did. Everyone needs a Willie. Everyone needs a Willie. He's your classic. He's another of your absolute classic. 70s British politicians who looks like, you know, the most shambling, woolly person you've
所以他的副手威利·怀特劳飞往贝尔法斯特。我们在撒切尔那一集见过他。我们见过。每个人都需要一个威利。每个人都需要一个威利。他是你的经典。他是你的另一个绝对经典。70年代的英国政客，看起来像，你知道，最邋遢、最毛茸茸的人，你
ever met and yet was a tank commander in Normandy. He has massive red cheeks and kind of little red veins running up to his oyster eyes, doesn't he? Oysterized. You've got to say oysterized by law when you talk about Willie White Law. And actually, he inspires great loyalty. I think he does a pretty good job of this,
见过，但却是诺曼底的坦克指挥官。他有巨大的红脸颊，还有那种一直延伸到他牡蛎眼睛的小红静脉，不是吗？牡蛎眼。当你谈论威利·怀特劳时，你必须依法说牡蛎眼。实际上，他激发了极大的忠诚。我认为他在这方面做得相当不错，
actually. The top civil servants in Northern Ireland, Kenneth Bloomfield said it was one of the great pleasures of my life to enjoy the company and the confidence of that large, emotional, sometimes irascible, apparently is spontaneous but infinitely cunning man. Imagine someone's saying that about you. That's brilliant.
实际上。北爱尔兰的顶级公务员肯尼斯·布卢姆菲尔德说，享受那个大个子、情绪化、有时易怒、表面上自发但无限狡猾的人的陪伴和信任，是我一生中最大的乐趣之一。想象一下有人那样评价你。那太棒了。
And White Law, to be fair to him, he assembles the team, and he says, I mean, the same thing to say, really, However awful things are outside, however many bombs go off, when we're together in private, we're going to enjoy ourselves. That's the mordling spirit. That is very much the wretching mortling spirit. I mean, the country is descending into the abyss, but we've got an absolutely terrific drinks cabinet.
怀特劳，对他公平一点，他组建了团队，他说，我的意思是，同样的话，真的，无论外面有多糟糕，无论发生多少次炸弹袭击，当我们私下在一起时，我们要享受自己。那是莫德林精神。那是非常令人痛苦的莫德林精神。我的意思是，国家正在坠入深渊，但我们有一个绝对棒的酒柜。
However, you know, the challenges that he faces are awful. So obviously the Catholics are completely alienated, but so now are a lot of the Protestants who have swung very much towards the more hardline extreme. Now, a person who sadly, for fans of your accents, has not featured much in last couple of episodes, is the Reverend Ian Paisley. And people may wonder why. And actually, this is quite a sort of a fallow period in Paisley's rhetorical career. Well, he's become an MP, hasn't he? He's become an MP, so he's gone off to London, so he's not even there. The flesh pots of Westminster.
然而，你知道，他面临的挑战是可怕的。所以显然天主教徒完全被疏远了，但现在很多新教徒也一样，他们已经非常转向更强硬的极端。现在，一个不幸的是，对于你的口音粉丝来说，在过去几集中没有太多出现的人，是伊恩·佩斯利牧师。人们可能想知道为什么。实际上，这是佩斯利修辞生涯中一个相当休耕的时期。嗯，他已经成为议员了，不是吗？他已经成为议员了，所以他去了伦敦，所以他甚至不在那里。威斯敏斯特的肉欲之所。
Exactly. But also, he's sort of all over the place politically at this point. He's been left behind a bit. He'd sort of slightly willed this sort of a crisis into being by his incredibly inflammatory rhetoric. But now that it has arrived, he doesn't really know where he stands. So, for example, Paisley was very much against internment.
没错。但同时，他在政治上此时有点不知所措。他有点被抛在后面了。他通过极其煽动性的言论稍微促成了这种危机。但现在它已经到来，他真的不知道自己的立场。所以，例如，佩斯利非常反对拘留。
Paisley was also unusually for a hardline in favour of direct rule from Westminster and scrapping Stormonts. I suppose because he thought Stormont was full of appeasers, probably, or something. So this leaves a vacancy for a man. who's largely forgotten now, but is a really extraordinary bloke, a bloke called William Craig. So William Craig had been O'Neill's
佩斯利在当时也不同寻常地支持威斯敏斯特的直接统治并废除斯托蒙特议会，这对于一个强硬派来说很罕见。我想可能是因为他认为斯托蒙特议会里全是绥靖主义者，或者类似的原因。这留下了一个空缺，由一个现在大多已被遗忘，但确实是个非常了不起的人来填补，他叫威廉·克雷格。所以威廉·克雷格曾是奥尼尔的
Home Affairs Minister, and he's been moving steadily to the right. Craig sees this, you know, he basically sees the vacancy on the right of Ulster Unionist politics, and he thinks, I will be the hardliners hardliner. And he founded his own party in February
内政部长，他一直在稳步向右翼靠拢。克雷格看到了这一点，他基本上看到了阿尔斯特统一主义政治右翼的空缺，他想，我要做强硬派中的强硬派。于是他在二月成立了自己的政党
1972 called Ulster Vanguard. And it looks like something, I have to say, if There are Ulster Vanguard listeners, I hope they're not going to be hideously offended. When I say, it looks like the sort of fascist party you would imagine in a TV series set an alternative universe 1970s Britain. Or what's his name in Reggie Perrin? Oh, the bloke who wants to set up his own private army. Jeffrey Palmer.
1972年，名为“阿尔斯特先锋”。我必须得说，它看起来有点……如果这里有“阿尔斯特先锋”的听众，我希望他们不会感到被严重冒犯。当我说它看起来像你在一部以20世纪70年代英国为背景的平行宇宙电视剧里能想象到的那种法西斯政党时。或者像《雷吉·佩林》里那个叫什么名字的人？哦，那个想建立自己私人军队的家伙。杰弗里·帕尔默。
Jeffrey Palmer. I think it's more sinister than Jeffrey Palmer, frankly. They have a very fascistic logo, which you can see online, which is a kind of blue V. That's never a good sign. At rallies, he has an honour guard that surrounds him. They wear uniforms with an orange sash. And they also do a kind of Nazi salute. Now, you know what it is?
杰弗里·帕尔默。坦率地说，我觉得它比杰弗里·帕尔默更阴险。他们有一个非常法西斯化的标志，你可以在网上看到，是一个蓝色的V字。这从来都不是什么好兆头。在集会上，他有一支护卫队环绕着他。他们穿着带有橙色饰带的制服。他们还会行一种纳粹礼。现在，你知道那是什么吗？
It's a national theatre reimagining of a Shakespeare Roman play. Daring and edgy that no one's ever thought of before. That is exactly. Starring Maxine Peake. Christopher Eccleston. Yeah. It's basically, it's a national theatre. play produced in 2012, imagining what will happen when David Cameron introduces fascism in Britain.
那是国家剧院对莎士比亚罗马剧作的重新演绎。大胆而前卫，以前没人想到过。就是这样。由玛克辛·皮克、克里斯托弗·埃克莱斯顿主演。是的。这基本上是国家剧院在2012年制作的一部剧，想象大卫·卡梅伦在英国引入法西斯主义后会发生什么。
That's what it is. Or in alliance with the fossil fuels industry. So, Christopher Regleston is so involved in this. Yeah, he totally is. He's Coriolanus. Okay, but this bloke, Craig, he is so aggressive. He gives a speech to 60,000 people in Belfast, loyalists. He says, we must build up dossiers on the men.
就是这样。或者与化石燃料行业结盟。所以，克里斯托弗·埃克莱斯顿也参与其中。是的，他完全参与了。他演的是科里奥兰纳斯。好吧，但这个叫克雷格的家伙，他太激进了。他在贝尔法斯特对6万名效忠派发表了演讲。他说，我们必须建立那些人的档案，
and women who are a menace to this country. Because one day, ladies and gentlemen, if the politicians fail us, it may be our job to liquidate the enemy. I don't feel you should be talking about liquidating the enemy. Well, those are the kind of comments of people who like The Odyssey from people on X. It's about you. Yeah, I know. Let's just Elon Musk.
那些对这个国家构成威胁的男女。因为有一天，女士们先生们，如果政客们辜负了我们，清算敌人可能就是我们的工作了。我觉得你不应该谈论清算敌人。好吧，那些是喜欢X平台上《奥德赛》的人的评论。那是关于你的。是的，我知道。让我们只谈埃隆·马斯克。
I know. We are at war. We must round up these people who like Christopher Nolan films and shoot them. I'll just give you a flavour of the comments I got. But there's actually more to come from Muskstroke William Craig. So at one point he's invited to address the Monday Club, the hard right conservative club at the House of Commons. He goes to the House of Commons. Drink has been taken and he throws caution to the wind and he says to his audience of Tory MPs,
我知道。我们处于战争状态。我们必须把这些喜欢克里斯托弗·诺兰电影的人抓起来枪毙。我只是给你尝尝我收到的评论。但马斯克式的威廉·克雷格还有更多表现。有一次他被邀请在下议院的极右翼保守派俱乐部“周一俱乐部”发表演讲。他去了下议院。酒过三巡，他抛开了顾虑，对他的托利党议员听众说，
if a British government stands in our way and don't forget there is a conservative government at this point, he says, I have 80,000 men ready to take up arms against them. We are prepared to come out and shoot and kill. I am prepared to kill. And those behind me have my full support. When we say force, we mean force. And what does the Monday Club? What's their reaction to this?
如果英国政府阻碍我们——别忘了当时是保守党政府——他说，我有8万名随时准备拿起武器对抗他们的人。我们准备好走上街头开枪杀人。我准备好杀人了。我身后的人全力支持我。当我们说武力时，我们指的就是武力。那么“周一俱乐部”有什么反应呢？
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, they hear here, and then they start talking about Rhodesia, surely. I mean, that's basically the vibe, isn't it? Now, you may say, does this man really have 80,000 people behind him? I don't think he has 80,000, but I do think he has thousands. So his movement was very closely allied to the UDA, the Ulster Defense Association, the vigilance, anti-alliance that we talked about last time. So they at this point are at their absolute peak.
是的，是的，是的，是的。是的，他们高喊“说得好”，然后他们开始谈论罗得西亚，当然。我的意思是，这基本上就是那种氛围，不是吗？现在，你可能会说，这个人真的有8万人支持他吗？我不认为他有8万，但我确实认为他有几千人。所以他的运动与UDA（阿尔斯特防卫协会）联系非常紧密，就是我们上次谈到的那个警惕的、反联盟的组织。所以他们在这一点上处于绝对的巅峰。
They had not been prescribed by the government, unlike other paramilitary groups. So they will march openly through the streets. You can see, you can Google photos of them. They will sort of wander through the streets and their dark glasses and military fatigues. They're very popular on the Protestant estates. And I think a reason for this and something underappreciated, I think I mentioned this in the first episode, I think massively underappreciating the story's the economic context. This is a point where on a lot of these estates, unemployment among young men, it's at least 20% in some estates it's 40 or 50%.
他们没有像其他准军事组织那样被政府取缔。所以他们会公开在街上游行。你可以看到，你可以在谷歌上搜到他们的照片。他们会戴着深色眼镜，穿着军装，在街上晃荡。他们在新教徒聚居区非常受欢迎。我认为这有一个原因，而且是被低估的一点，我想我在第一集提到过，我认为极大地低估了这个故事的经济背景。这是在许多这些聚居区，年轻男性的失业率至少达到20%，在一些聚居区甚至达到40%或50%。
Basically, there are a lot of 20-year-old men who left school five years earlier or four years earlier or whatever and have nothing to do. So it's a slightly Vimar vibe. Possibly, yeah. It's also, I mean, the one thing we haven't really talked about, I think also underappreciated, why do people join all these groups? It's fun. It's fun.
基本上，有很多20岁的年轻人，他们在四五年前就辍学了，无所事事。所以这有点魏玛共和国的氛围。可能吧，是的。而且，我们还没有真正讨论过的一点，我认为也被低估了，为什么人们会加入所有这些组织？这很有趣。这很有趣。
Right. They like dressing up. They like being given a gun. They're like hanging around with their mates. Violent Boy Scouts. Completely. And the UDA, I mean, the UDA don't have the ideological aspirations of the IRA. They are basically vigilantes stroke gangsters.
对。他们喜欢打扮。他们喜欢被发给一把枪。他们喜欢和朋友们混在一起。暴力的童子军。完全正确。而且UDA，我的意思是，UDA没有IRA（爱尔兰共和军）那样的意识形态抱负。他们基本上就是治安维持者兼黑帮。
So there's no spiritual crisis for them? I don't think so. They run protection rackets. They will hijack lorries with TVs in or cigarettes or alcohol or something. I mean, that's, again, a difference with Paisley, isn't it? Because Paisley is a man of God, even if that is a god of wrath. So he does have to consider what the Bible tells him and the future of his soul and everything. But these guys, they're not.
所以他们没有精神危机？我不这么认为。他们经营保护费勒索。他们会劫持装有电视机、香烟或酒精之类的卡车。我的意思是，这又是一个与佩斯利的不同之处，不是吗？因为佩斯利是一个上帝的信徒，即使那是愤怒之神。所以他确实必须考虑圣经告诉他的内容，以及他的灵魂的未来等等。但这些人，他们不是。
No, Ian Paisley never hijacked a lorry carrying bottles of, you know, what's a bushmills? Is that a thing? That's like a Northern Irish thing, isn't it? Anyway. Yeah, and journalists would go out to the UDA training camps to inspect them, and they always scoffed at them. So Peter Taylor watched them training outside Belfast, and he reported as follows, a series of overweight loyalists panted for breath as they monkey climbed a rope suspended above the ground and went through the motions of less than agile hand-to-hand combat.
不，伊恩·佩斯利从未劫持过一辆装满瓶装……你知道，什么是布什米尔斯（Bushmills）？那是某种东西吗？那是北爱尔兰的东西，不是吗？总之。是的，记者们会去UDA训练营视察他们，他们总是嘲笑他们。所以彼得·泰勒看着他们在贝尔法斯特外训练，他报道如下：一系列超重的效忠派在悬挂在地面上的绳子上攀爬时气喘吁吁，并做着笨拙的肉搏动作。
Just jump on people, crush them. And Kevin Myers said they were, he doesn't take them seriously at all in his memoir. And he says they were the only terrorist group in the world who designed their own regimental blazer, complete with gold badge. Anyway, there's been too much laughter because there's nothing funny about loyalists. violence in the summer of 72. This is the bloodiest year, the troubles. It's the peak of sectarian killings. These loyalist paramilitary
就是跳到人身上，压垮他们。凯文·迈尔斯在他的回忆录中说他们是，他根本没把他们当回事。他说他们是世界上唯一一个设计了自己的团徽章西装外套，还配有金质徽章的恐怖组织。总之，笑得太多了，因为效忠派的暴力在72年夏天一点也不好笑。这是“动乱”中最血腥的一年。这是宗派杀戮的巅峰。这些效忠派准军事
people probably killed about 120 people that year. And these people were not other paramilitaries. They are Catholic civilians just walking down the street, dragged out of pubs, sometimes attacked in their own homes. And to put that into context, the British Army killed just under 90 people
人员那一年可能杀害了大约120人。而这些人不是其他准军事人员。他们只是走在街上的天主教平民，被从酒吧里拖出来，有时在自己家里遭到袭击。为了说明这一点，英国军队杀害了不到90人
in 1972. The official IRA killed 20 people. and the provisional IRA killed almost 230 people. Now, talking of the provisional IRA, they are cocker hoop with the demise of Stormont. I mean, they were only founded at the turn of 1970, and we're in the middle of 1972. The Northern Irish Parliament, which they hated, is gone, and the nationalist population has been well and truly radicalised.
在1972年。官方爱尔兰共和军杀害了20人，而临时派爱尔兰共和军杀害了近230人。现在，说到临时派爱尔兰共和军，他们对斯托蒙特议会的倒台感到欣喜若狂。我的意思是，他们是在1970年初才成立的，而我们现在是在1972年中期。他们所憎恨的北爱尔兰议会已经不复存在，民族主义人口也确实被彻底激进化了。
As they see it, they are well on the way to achieving their goals. I mean, one IRA man said as follows, everyone felt we were very close to victory. Most people on the ground felt it was only a matter of time before the British were finally going to admit defeat. And so that explains why at this point, spring summer 1972, they do something which some listeners may be surprised by. They are very happy to talk to the British about ending this whole thing because, as they see it, they are in the position of basically dictating the terms of the British. surrender. So on the 13th of June, they held a press conference in Derry. If the British will agree to peace talks, would declare a ceasefire. And Willie Whitelaw says, you know, publicly he says no,
在他们看来，他们离实现目标已经不远了。我的意思是，一名爱尔兰共和军成员说：每个人都觉得我们离胜利非常近。地面上的大多数人都觉得英国人承认失败只是时间问题。所以这就解释了为什么在此时，1972年的春夏，他们做了一件可能让一些听众感到惊讶的事情。他们非常乐意与英国人谈论结束这一切，因为在他们看来，他们基本上处于可以决定英国投降条款的位置。所以6月13日，他们在德里举行了新闻发布会。如果英国人同意和谈，他们就会宣布停火。威利·怀特劳公开表示拒绝，
but obviously privately he's thinking, well, it'd be mad not to talk to them. Six days later, he quietly met two of their ceasefire conditions. So first of all, he awarded IRA prisoners special category status, which means they will not be treated as common criminals. They will be treated as political prisoners. So, for example, they can wear their own clothes, which becomes a huge deal in the hunger strikes in 1981. And the other condition, he agrees to release a bearded young man who has been interned on a prison ship, HMS Maidstone, and this young man has been accused of being a commander of a Belfast IRA battalion. This young man is the 23-year-old Jerry Adams, who, as you know, Tom, maintains that he was never a member of the IRA. So he's been
但私下里他显然在想，不和他们谈才疯了。六天后，他悄悄满足了他们两个停火条件。首先，他授予爱尔兰共和军囚犯特殊类别地位，这意味着他们不会被视为普通罪犯。他们将被视为政治犯。例如，他们可以穿自己的衣服，这在1981年的绝食抗议中成了一个大问题。另一个条件是，他同意释放一名被关押在监狱船“梅德斯通号”上的留着胡子的年轻人，这名年轻人被指控是贝尔法斯特爱尔兰共和军营的指挥官。这个年轻人就是23岁的杰里·亚当斯，正如你所知，汤姆，他坚称自己从未加入过爱尔兰共和军。所以他被
wrongly interned. In his own mind, wrongly interred, and indeed wrongly. Well, I mean, his entire presence in the next few minutes of this episode is bewildering. A terrible... It's bewildering.
错误地关押了。在他自己看来，是被错误地关押了，确实也错了。好吧，我的意思是，他在接下来几分钟的节目中的出现令人困惑。一个可怕的……这令人困惑。
Mistaken identity. It's a terrible case of mistaken identity. What's that barman doing there? He's inexplicably being invited to all these meetings when he has nothing to contribute. So the day after Adams was released, two British officials
身份认同错误。这是一个可怕的身份认同错误案例。那个酒保在那里干什么？当他毫无贡献时，他却莫名其妙地被邀请参加所有这些会议。所以亚当斯被释放后的第二天，两名英国官员
drive to a country house outside dairy. One of them is white Senior Civil Servant, Philip Woodfield, and the other is a senior MI6 officer called Frank Steele. And waiting for them are an IRA man since the 1950s called David O'Connell and, baffling me, Jerry Adams. So you're kind of intern, work placement. Yeah. Who knows?
开车前往德里郊外的一座乡村别墅。其中一人是怀特劳的高级公务员菲利普·伍德菲尔德，另一人是名为弗兰克·斯蒂尔的军情六处高级官员。等待他们的是一名自20世纪50年代以来的爱尔兰共和军成员大卫·奥康奈尔，以及令人困惑的杰里·亚当斯。所以你算是被关押，工作安置。是的。谁知道呢？
Who knows why he's there? So for three hours, they have this meeting and they agree a deal. They'll have a temporary IRA ceasefire, steal, the MI6 man. And O'Connell basically set up a telephone hotline so they can talk to each other. And the IRA will meet with White Law himself. And Woodfield reports to White Law. He says, the mood at this meeting, this again may surprise listeners. He says the mood was very informal and very relaxed.
谁知道他为什么在那里？所以他们开了三个小时的会，达成了一项协议。他们将进行临时的爱尔兰共和军停火，斯蒂尔，那个军情六处的家伙。奥康奈尔基本上建立了一条电话热线，这样他们就可以互相交谈。爱尔兰共和军将与怀特劳本人会面。伍德菲尔德向怀特劳汇报。他说，这次会议的气氛，这可能又会让听众感到惊讶。他说气氛非常非正式且非常轻松。
The two Irishmen were respectable and respectful throughout. They made no bombastic defence of their past. And they made no attacks on the British government, the British army. or any other communities or bodies in Northern Ireland. Their response to every argument put to them was reasonable and moderate. And he says to White Law, I think they genuinely want a ceasefire and a permanent end to violence. Now, sort of more hardline listers may say, gosh, this bloke's gone completely native.
两名爱尔兰人自始至终都很体面且恭敬。他们没有对自己的过去进行任何夸夸其谈的辩护。他们也没有攻击英国政府、英国军队或北爱尔兰的任何其他社区或机构。他们对提出的每一个论点的回应都是理性和温和的。他对怀特劳说，我认为他们真心想要停火并永久结束暴力。现在，一些更强硬的听众可能会说，天哪，这家伙完全被同化了。
But the MI6 man, Steele, went even further. He said of David O'Connell. He was a very quiet, self-contained and self-disciplined man. I know it's an unfashionable thing to say, but I liked him. and he has a remarkable exchange with Jerry Adams whom Steele finds very personal and intelligent and Steele said to Adams you don't want to spend the rest of your life on the run from us British
但军情六处的斯蒂尔走得更远。他谈到大卫·奥康奈尔时说：他是一个非常安静、克制且自律的人。我知道这话说出来不合时宜，但我喜欢他。他与杰里·亚当斯进行了一次非凡的交流，斯蒂尔发现亚当斯非常有个性且聪明，斯蒂尔对亚当斯说，你不想余生都在躲避我们英国人吧，
what do you want to do with your life and Adam said to him I want to go to university and get a degree and Steele said but we're not stopping you all you've got to do is renounce violence and you can go to university and get a degree and Adams actually stopped and thought for a minute or two
你想用你的余生做什么？亚当斯对他说，我想去上大学，拿个学位。斯蒂尔说，但我们并没有阻止你，你所要做的就是放弃暴力，你就可以去上大学拿学位。亚当斯竟然停下来思考了一两分钟，
and then said to Steele no I've got to help to get rid of you British first. How do you do that if you're just a barman? So, I mean, he would say through political means, through membership of Sinn Féin, but not the IRA, wouldn't he? Would he not? Yeah, I guess he would. So two days later, they announced a ceasefire to begin on Monday, the 26th of June, and then on the 7th of July, a really extraordinary moment. Top secret, an IRA delegation is flown to London for secret talks with Willie Whitelaw. Four of them are long-standing IRA men, but two of them are much
然后对斯蒂尔说，不，我得先帮着把你们英国人赶走。如果你只是个酒保，你怎么做得到？所以，我的意思是，他会说通过政治手段，通过加入新芬党，而不是爱尔兰共和军，不是吗？难道不是吗？是的，我想他会这么说。所以两天后，他们宣布从6月26日星期一开始停火，然后在7月7日，一个非常非凡的时刻。绝密，一个爱尔兰共和军代表团被飞往伦敦，与威利·怀特劳进行秘密会谈。其中四人是老资格的爱尔兰共和军成员，但有两人要年轻得多。其中一个是马丁·麦吉尼斯，他是德里爱尔兰共和军的二把手，曾出现在“血腥星期日”现场。另一个，又是身份认同错误。没人知道为什么他在那儿，杰里·亚当斯。还有马丁·麦吉尼斯？是的，马丁·麦吉尼斯，没错。板球和PG·伍德豪斯的忠实粉丝。马丁·麦吉尼斯是板球迷吗？他热爱板球。是的，他热爱。而且他喜欢PG·伍德豪斯。是的。哇。我哥哥是杰里·亚当斯的宣传代理人。当然他是。我忘了这一点。而且马丁·麦吉尼斯是一个非常有魅力的人。我的意思是，他和伊恩·佩斯利也相处得很好。当然，是“咯咯笑兄弟”。
younger. One of them is Martin McGuinness, who is the second in command of the Derry IRA and was present at Bloody Sunday. And the other, yet again, mistaken identity. No one knows where is there, Jerry Adams. And Martin McGuinness? Yeah, Martin McGuinness, exactly. Big fan of cricket and PG Woodhouse. Was Martin McGinnis a fan of cricket? He loved it. Yeah, he loved it. And he liked PG Woodhouse. Yeah. Wow. My brother was Jerry Adams' publicity agent. Of course he was. I'd forgotten that. And Martin Guinness was a very charming man. I mean, it got on very well with Ian Paisley as well. Of course, the Chuckle Brothers.
（注：此处原文索引156与155内容有重叠，按原意翻译）
Just to clear this up for listeners, your brother was Jerry Adams' agent in his capacity as a publisher. Yes, yes, his book had come out. Your brother was not a member of Sinn Féin. I mean, that's a hell of a twist. Although, Jerry Adams would always send him a Christmas card and there would be, you know, happy Christmas. And there'd be a kind of a Christmas tree wrapped up in
为了向听众澄清这一点，你哥哥是杰里·亚当斯作为出版商的代理人。是的，是的，他的书出版了。你哥哥不是新芬党成员。我的意思是，这真是一个惊人的转折。虽然，杰里·亚当斯总是会给他寄圣诞贺卡，上面会写着，你知道，圣诞快乐。而且会有一种圣诞树被包裹在
barbed wire. Oh my God. It stuck out in his Wilcher cottage. And also, Jerry Adams and Christmas cards, the best ever moment in the history of social media. Oh, yes. It's when Jerry Adams said, I was trying to reinvent himself on social media as a vunkular grandfather and said he was having trouble with his Christmas lights. Can no one give me a lighter? Yeah.
铁丝网里。天哪。它插在他威尔特郡的小屋里。而且，杰里·亚当斯和圣诞贺卡，社交媒体史上最棒的时刻。哦，是的。就是当杰里·亚当斯试图在社交媒体上重塑自己为一个慈祥的祖父形象，说他在圣诞彩灯上遇到了麻烦。没人能给我一个打火机吗？是的。
Somebody replied and said, surely you must know somebody you can fit a timer. But of course he wouldn't because he wasn't a member of that organisation. He had terrible problem with wind and he was a great way. He was better out than it. Ah, terrible. I knew he was a bad man. So they're flown, they're going to go to London. It's a farcical journey. Their car breaks down. All six of the delegates have to cram into one car. They're picked up by an MI6 minivan. The minivan gets stuck behind a farmer and some cows, a very Irish scene. And finally, they get to London. They're driven to Chelsea to a place called Cheney Walk. It's the home of White Law's junior minister, Paul Channon. It's a really hot day. Whitelaw is waiting for them. He offers them drinks. They refills. They refere fuse. There's some suspicion that they might have thought White was going to poison them. I think that's obviously ludicrous. He wasn't going to poison them. I think it's much more that they are, because there's so many of them, they can't really relax because they're all watching each other.
有人回复说，你肯定认识能装定时器的人。但当然他不会，因为他不是那个组织的成员。他有严重的风力问题，他是个伟大的方式。他最好还是别提了。啊，太糟糕了。我知道他是个坏人。所以他们被飞往伦敦。这是一次滑稽的旅程。他们的车坏了。所有六名代表不得不挤进一辆车。他们被一辆军情六处的面包车接走。面包车被困在一位农民和几头牛后面，这是一个非常爱尔兰的场景。最后，他们到达了伦敦。他们被开车送到切尔西一个叫切尼步道的地方。那是怀特劳的初级部长保罗·钱农的家。那天非常热。怀特劳在等他们。他给他们提供饮料。他们拒绝了。有人怀疑他们可能认为怀特劳要毒死他们。我认为这显然很荒谬。他不会毒死他们。我认为更多是因为他们人太多，他们无法真正放松，因为他们都在互相监视。
And of course, there is a precedent for IRA men going to London, which we've done on the rest is history, the Anglo-Irish treaty negotiations. And then all the talk was, you know, selling out and people becoming, you know, Michael Collins falling for the blandishments, the British. So they are determined not to do this and they're very stiff and serious. And the tone is set by the IRA chief of staff, a man who calls himself Sean McSiefen. And he is an absolutely extraordinary figure. I mean, he's basically a massive fraud, right? I mean, he is a massive fraud.
当然，爱尔兰共和军成员去伦敦是有先例的，我们在《历史的其余部分》中讲过，即《英爱条约》谈判。当时所有的谈话都是关于，你知道，出卖，人们变得，你知道，迈克尔·柯林斯被英国人的甜言蜜语所迷惑。所以他们决心不这样做，他们非常僵硬和严肃。基调是由爱尔兰共和军参谋长设定的，一个自称肖恩·麦西芬的人。他是一个绝对非凡的人物。我的意思是，他基本上是个巨大的骗子，对吧？我的意思是，他是个巨大的骗子。
So his real name, as it were, is John Stevenson. and he was from East London. His father was not Irish, but an English legal clerk. His mother was Bethel Green born and bred. She did have Irish blood, but Ulster Protestant blood. But he's like the kind of guy who's incredibly English, but insists on supporting Ireland in rugby matches. Exactly.
所以他的真名，姑且这么说，是约翰·史蒂文森。他来自东伦敦。他的父亲不是爱尔兰人，而是一名英国法律职员。他的母亲是贝思纳尔格林土生土长的。她确实有爱尔兰血统，但那是阿尔斯特新教徒的血统。但他就像那种非常英国化，却坚持在橄榄球比赛中支持爱尔兰的家伙。没错。
He goes to a leading public school and wears an Ireland rugby shirt. That's exactly the kind of man this is, Although from Beth of more Bethnal Green kind of vintage. So he was in the RAF. For some reason, I don't know, he got radicalized. He learned Irish. He changed his name, galicized it, became ultra-Catholic, and basically became more Irish than the Irish.
他去了一所顶尖的公立学校，穿着爱尔兰橄榄球衫。这正是那种人，尽管来自贝思纳尔格林那种年代。所以他在皇家空军服役。出于某种原因，我不知道，他激进化了。他学习了爱尔兰语。他改了名字，盖尔语化了，成了极端的天主教徒，基本上变得比爱尔兰人还爱尔兰人。
And what would drive him mad is that the other IRA men used to call him the Englishman. Which he was. He was. Exactly. But because he was more Irish than the Irish, so he was ultra-Catholic, he didn't drink, he didn't smoke, He was passionately anti-abortion. He had no sense of humour.
让他发疯的是，其他爱尔兰共和军成员过去常叫他“英国佬”。他确实是。他确实是。没错。但因为他比爱尔兰人还爱尔兰人，所以他是极端天主教徒，他不喝酒，不抽烟，他热情地反对堕胎。他没有幽默感。
His hard work, basically. So he's quite de Valera. Yeah, a little bit. I mean, we talked before, when we were talking about the late furor of Nazi Germany, what a terrible person he'd be to have at your wedding.
他的努力工作，基本上。所以他很像德瓦莱拉。是的，有点。我的意思是，我们之前谈过，当我们谈论纳粹德国的最后狂热时，他在你的婚礼上会是一个多么糟糕的人。
This bloke would be awful as a wedding guest because, of course, like Hitler, doesn't drink, doesn't smoke. And is only going to talk to you with the sort of, apparently he would adopt a fake Irish accent. Kevin Myers in his memoir is very simplistic about his fake.
这家伙作为婚礼宾客会很糟糕，因为当然，像希特勒一样，不喝酒，不抽烟。而且只会用那种，显然他会采用一种虚假的爱尔兰口音和你说话。凯文·迈尔斯在他的回忆录中对他那种虚假的口音描述得很简单。
Like that S&P. Yeah, the SMP woman who has the fake Scottish accent. Who changes her accent depending on where she is. So he does the talking anyway at this meeting, presumably in his accent. He reads a list of demands. He says, we need you to release all that prisoners, total British withdrawal you've got till 1975, and have an all-Ireland referendum on ending partition. So if he doesn't say you've got to get out nigh.
就像那个苏格兰民族党（SNP）的人。是的，那个有虚假苏格兰口音的苏格兰民族党女人。根据她在哪里而改变口音。所以他在这次会议上负责说话，大概是用他的口音。他读了一份要求清单。他说，我们需要你们释放所有囚犯，英国全面撤军，你们有时间到1975年，并就结束分裂举行全爱尔兰公投。所以如果他不说是你必须现在就滚。
No, he does not. So the all-Ireland referendum on ending partition, of course an all-Ireland referendum would mean the end of Northern Ireland. The British position is and always has been, and indeed from the 1990s, the Irish position, is that this is for the people of Northern Ireland as a distinct unit to decide, but that's not the IRA's position.
不，他没有。所以关于结束分裂的全爱尔兰公投，当然全爱尔兰公投意味着北爱尔兰的终结。英国的立场一直都是，实际上从1990年代开始，爱尔兰的立场也是，这是由北爱尔兰人民作为一个独特的单位来决定的，但这并不是爱尔兰共和军的立场。
I mean, the North Ireland referendum, would it definitely? I guess the emotional case for it would be so strong, wouldn't it? But the practical code, it would be head and heart. The emotional case would be very strong. If you're living in like, I don't know, Waterford, in 1972 and somebody says, would you now feel her life would be materially improved
我的意思是，北爱尔兰公投，会确定吗？我想情感上的理由会非常强烈，不是吗？但实际的代码，那将是理智与情感。情感上的理由会非常强烈。如果你住在，我不知道，1972年的沃特福德，有人说，你现在会觉得你的生活会得到实质性的改善吗
by the addition of Northern Ireland, with all of its issues, to your national unit? What would you think? I mean, I think the national case would be so strong. Yes, I think you wouldn't be able to resist the promptings of your heart, but your head might say, I'm not sure.
通过将北爱尔兰及其所有问题加入到你的国家单位中？你会怎么想？我的意思是，我认为民族理由会非常强烈。是的，我想你无法抗拒内心的呼唤，但你的理智可能会说，我不确定。
Yeah, this is not ideal. Anyway, the IRA clearly have misread this situation because there is no way the British are going to give into this. And it became obvious, I think, to White Law and to Frank Steele, who was there. The IRA basically thought they'd won and the British were negotiating their surrender. And that was a complete and utter misreading of the situation. So it breaks up the meeting.
是的，这并不理想。总之，爱尔兰共和军显然误读了这种情况，因为英国人绝不可能屈服于此。我认为，这对怀特劳和在场的弗兰克·斯蒂尔来说变得显而易见。爱尔兰共和军基本上认为他们赢了，英国人正在谈判他们的投降。这完全是对情况的彻底误读。所以会议解散了。
They go back to Belfast. And Steele is with them. The MI6 man is with them the whole time. And he says to them on the flight back, I'm so disappointed. And he says to them, I hope you're not going to go back to your bloody stupid campaign of violence. I said, if they really want to,
他们回到贝尔法斯特。斯蒂尔和他们在一起。那个军情六处的家伙全程和他们在一起。他在回程的飞机上对他们说，我太失望了。他对他们说，我希望你们不要回到你们那该死的愚蠢的暴力运动中去。我说，如果他们真的想要，
to a United Ireland. They were wasting their time shooting at British soldiers and bombing Northern Ireland into an industrial and social slum. They should be trying to persuade the Protestants that they would have some sort of satisfactory life, jobs, housing and so on, in some sort of linkage with the South. And still remembered later he said, no, they said to me, we've got to get rid of you British first. And the way to get rid of you, as has been proved all over your empire, is violence. You will get fed up and go away. And you could see. why that might not be a wholly unreasonable perspective. That we've been saying throughout that people in mainland Britain are weary and bored of it, they're not interested, they wish it would all go away. People in the IRA are not stupid. I mean, they're keeping track of British public opinion. They must know this. I mean, that is why in due course they're going to start bombing the mainland.
实现爱尔兰统一。他们是在浪费时间向英国士兵开枪，把北爱尔兰炸成一个工业和社会贫民窟。他们应该试图说服新教徒，让他们在与南方的某种联系中，过上某种令人满意的生活，有工作、住房等等。斯蒂尔后来回忆说，不，他们对我说，我们得先赶走你们英国人。而赶走你们的方法，正如在你们整个帝国所证明的那样，就是暴力。你们会厌倦并离开。你可以看出。
But actually, they don't withdraw. No, they don't. But actually, one of the reasons I think is that precisely because the RA do start bombing the British mainland, actually. So I think once the IRA do that, there is no way the British would ever withdraw. Because you cannot surrender to the men of violence. No, but, I mean, you can't, I mean, to blow,
为什么这可能不是一个完全不合理的观点。我们一直说，英国本土的人们对此感到厌倦和无聊，他们不感兴趣，他们希望这一切都消失。爱尔兰共和军的人并不傻。我的意思是，他们一直在关注英国的公众舆论。他们一定知道这一点。我的意思是，这就是为什么他们最终会开始轰炸本土。
if you blow up British pubs in Birmingham, Guildford and so on, if you blow up a coach on the M62, if you blow, you know, bombs in London, if you have bombs in Piccadilly, all of that stuff, once you do that, then that will harden the British public against, to you. I think the IRA completely misread the British Republic in that regard. There was no way they were ever going to withdraw once the
但实际上，他们并没有撤退。不，他们没有。但实际上，我认为原因之一正是因为爱尔兰共和军确实开始轰炸英国本土。所以我想一旦爱尔兰共和军那样做了，英国人就绝不可能撤退。因为你不能向暴力分子投降。不，但是，我的意思是，你不能，我的意思是，去炸，
IRA attacked Britain itself. The tragic irony of all this is that if they'd done a deal then in 1972, they'd have probably got what they got in the late 1990s. A lot of lives would have been saved. But of course, the reason they don't do the deal is because they think they'll get a
如果你炸毁伯明翰、吉尔福德等地的英国酒吧，如果你炸毁M62公路上的长途汽车，如果你炸毁，你知道，伦敦的炸弹，如果你在皮卡迪利有炸弹，所有这些事情，一旦你做了，那么这就会使英国公众对你变得强硬。我认为爱尔兰共和军在那方面完全误读了英国公众。一旦
better outcome by fighting. I think there's that. Plus, I think at the time, the Conflict is not very old. And this is probably, again, an heretical thing to say, but I think there are quite a lot of people who enjoy the conflict, actually, on both sides, loyalist and Republican. One IRA man said, maybe you can't bomb a million Protestants into United Ireland, but you could have good fun trying. And I think there are a lot of people, as horrendous as it will sound for some listeners, who actually found it very exciting. Yeah, the safe houses, the smuggling of guns, the operations, all of that.
爱尔兰共和军攻击英国本身，他们就绝不可能撤退。这一切的悲剧讽刺在于，如果他们在1972年达成协议，他们可能已经得到了他们在1990年代末得到的东西。许多生命本来可以被挽救。但当然，他们没有达成协议的原因是他们认为通过战斗会得到
And there are people in the British Army who find it exciting as well, aren't there? Though, you know, kind of undercover British officers. What's his name? Robert Nyrak. Yeah, Robert Nyrak. So a couple of days later, the ceasefire ends, street battles again. A huge new surge of violence. So nine days after the end of the ceasefire, the IRA, the UDA and the British Army between them killed 42 people.
更好的结果。我想有那个原因。另外，我认为当时冲突还不是很老。这可能又是一个异端邪说，但我认为实际上有相当多的人享受这种冲突，在双方都是如此，效忠派和共和派。一名爱尔兰共和军成员说，也许你不能把一百万新教徒炸进爱尔兰统一，但你可以尝试一下，这很有趣。我认为有很多人，尽管对一些听众来说听起来很可怕，但他们确实觉得这非常令人兴奋。是的，安全屋、走私枪支、行动，所有这些。
And by the end of 1972, to give you the stats, there'd been 2,000 bombings, 2,000 armed robberies, more than 10,000 shootings, 5,000 people badly wounded, 479 people killed. And to be honest, there's only so many of these atrocities we can really inflict on an audience. So Heath makes one more attempt to find a peaceful solution. There's a massive loyalist strike in 1974. There's, of course, the hunger strikes under Margaret Thatcher in 1981. We'll come back to that another time.
而且英国军队里也有人觉得这很令人兴奋，不是吗？虽然，你知道，某种卧底英国军官。他叫什么名字？罗伯特·奈拉克。是的，罗伯特·奈拉克。所以几天后，停火结束，街头战斗再次爆发。暴力事件再次激增。所以停火结束后九天，爱尔兰共和军、UDA和英国军队总共杀害了42人。
But I'll leave you with just a story that I think says so much about what happened to Northern Ireland in not an entirely joyful way. So on the afternoon of the 21st of July, that is two weeks. after the failure of these talks. The provisional set off 22 bombs in the centre of Belfast, and they gave a series of hoax warnings that confused the authorities that meant that they couldn't evacuate the scene. These bombs go off over the course of just over an hour.
到1972年底，给你统计一下，已经发生了2000起爆炸，2000起武装抢劫，超过10000起枪击，5000人受重伤，479人死亡。老实说，我们能强加给观众的这些暴行只有这么多。所以希思又做了一次寻找和平解决方案的尝试。1974年发生了大规模的效忠派罢工。当然，还有1981年玛格丽特·撒切尔领导下的绝食抗议。我们以后会再谈这个。
They killed nine people, and they seriously injured 130 people. And some of the bodies that were blown up, they were scattered so far that on the TV news that night, the pictures showed policemen literally scooping up body parts into back. And this went down as Bloody Friday. And it actually did tremendous damage to the IRA, lost them a lot of moderate nationalist support, and lost them support in America.
但我会留给你一个故事，我认为它充分说明了北爱尔兰发生了什么，而且并不完全是快乐的。所以7月21日下午，也就是这些会谈失败两周后。临时派在贝尔法斯特市中心引爆了22枚炸弹，他们发出了一系列误导当局的恶作剧警告，这意味着他们无法疏散现场。这些炸弹在不到一个小时的时间里相继爆炸。
And one of the victims, I mean, this is an awful story. One of the victims was a messenger boy who was 14 years old called Stephen Parker. And he had spotted a car bomb in Cave Hill Road, and he was trying to warn people when it went off and he was killed. And his father, the Reverend Joseph Parker, was a Church of Ireland chaplain at a sailor's mission in Belfast. And he went along, he was asked to identify his son's body, and it was so badly injured that he could only identify his son's body
他们杀死了9人，重伤了130人。有些被炸碎的尸体散落得太远，以至于那天晚上的电视新闻画面显示警察真的在用袋子收集尸体碎片。这被称为“血腥星期五”。它实际上对爱尔兰共和军造成了巨大的损害，使他们失去了许多温和的民族主义支持，也失去了在美国的支持。
by a box of trick matches that his son had shown him the night before in his pocket and his boy scout's belt, of which his son was very proud. And afterwards, the Reverend Parker set up a peace group in his son's memory. It was called Witness for Peace. and he held services outside City Hall in Belfast and also at the GPO in Dublin, and he would plant a white cross for every victim of the troubles. So quite moving story. But here's the twist.
其中一名受害者，我的意思是，这是一个可怕的故事。其中一名受害者是一个14岁的送信男孩，名叫斯蒂芬·帕克。他在凯夫山路发现了一枚汽车炸弹，他正试图警告人们时炸弹爆炸了，他被炸死了。他的父亲，约瑟夫·帕克牧师，是贝尔法斯特海员传教团的爱尔兰教会牧师。他去了现场，被要求辨认他儿子的尸体，尸体受损太严重，他只能通过
People didn't like it. They didn't like him campaigning for peace. His own church did not like it. His own bishop said, can you please stop talking about peace? It alienates our parishioners. And can you confine your peace activities? to your day off. And so in 1975, the Reverend Parker and his wife left Northern Ireland
他儿子前一天晚上给他看过的口袋里的一盒魔术火柴，以及他儿子非常自豪的童子军腰带，才辨认出他儿子的尸体。事后，帕克牧师以他儿子的名义建立了一个和平组织。它被称为“和平见证”。他在贝尔法斯特市政厅外以及都柏林的邮政总局举行仪式，他会为“动乱”中的每一位受害者种下一枚白十字架。所以这是一个非常感人的故事。但转折点在这里。
for good and they emigrated to Vancouver in Canada. And in the meantime, the killing went on. And Dominic, as you said, we will be returning to this story in due course. Still a long way to go before we reached the Good Friday Agreement. And there will as ever be more about this on this theme in our brilliant newsletter, which if you're not already signed up, you can get by signing up at the rest is history.com. Next week, we will be heading right back in time to ancient Rome, to the Roman Republic, and two of its most famous names, Marius and Sulla. And if you feel there haven't been enough civil war on the podcast recently, there will be Rome's first civil war as Marius and Sulla start tearing chunks out of each other. So all of that to come. And if you want to hear
人们不喜欢它。他们不喜欢他为和平奔走。他自己的教会不喜欢它。他自己的主教说，你能停止谈论和平吗？这疏远了我们的教区居民。你能把你和平活动的范围限制在你的休息日吗？所以1975年，帕克牧师和他的妻子永远离开了北爱尔兰，移民到了加拿大的温哥华。与此同时，杀戮还在继续。多米尼克，正如你所说，我们将在适当的时候回到这个故事。距离我们达成《耶稣受难日协议》还有很长的路要走。一如既往，我们的精彩时事通讯中会有更多关于这个主题的内容，如果你还没有订阅，你可以通过在therestishistory.com注册来获取。下周，我们将回到古罗马，回到罗马共和国，以及它最著名的两个名字，马略和苏拉。如果你觉得播客里最近的内战不够多，罗马的第一次内战将会上演，因为马略和苏拉开始互相撕咬。所以所有这些即将到来。如果你想在周一立即听到
all four episodes of that right away on Monday, again, you can sign up for them at the rest ishistri.com. But for now, Dominic, thank you for taking us through this grim story. And thank you everyone for listening. Bye bye. Bye-bye. Two and five Canadians will hear the words you have cancer. That's why every step and dollar-raised matters. On September 19th, join thousands in Toronto for the Princess Margaret Cancer Foundation Walk. Challenge yourself, friends, and family
那四集全部内容，同样，你可以在therestishistory.com注册。但现在，多米尼克，谢谢你带我们走过这个残酷的故事。也谢谢大家的收听。再见。再见。五分之二的加拿大人会听到“你得了癌症”这句话。这就是为什么每一步和筹集的每一美元都很重要。9月19日，加入多伦多的数千人参加玛格丽特公主癌症基金会步行活动。挑战你自己、朋友和家人
to walk 21 kilometers in support of life-saving research. Together, we can carry the fire and help create a world free from the fear of cancer. Register today at pmcfwalk.ca. When you buy furniture from Wayfair, you're not just getting furniture, you're setting your home up for a lifetime of
步行21公里，支持挽救生命的癌症研究。我们可以一起传递火炬，帮助创造一个没有癌症恐惧的世界。今天就在pmcfwalk.ca注册。当你从Wayfair购买家具时，你不仅是在购买家具，你是在为你的家建立一个终身的
Visit Wayfair.ca today or download the Wayfair app. Furniture made for all of life's moments. That's Wayfair. Wayfair, every style, every home. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
今天就访问Wayfair.ca或下载Wayfair应用程序。为生活中的所有时刻而制作的家具。这就是Wayfair。Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。